One tells a lie, the other tells the truth.
Which kitty could it be?
So like, as you guys know, I was looping because I have to wait for Mint a little bit.
So...
Oh yeah, she waited for Mint, you guys.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, she read out what she was typing and she was like, I'm looping because of Mint.
But literally right before that, she said...
I said like, don't worry, Mint, I'll wait for you.
No, you didn't!
That's what I said, right?
Yeah, that's literally what I said before I typed it out.
She said, I'm looping because I need more time.
And then she wrote out what she typed.
And then I sent mine before her.
Alright, so one tells a truth, the other tells a lie.
Which kitty could it be?
I think they know.
Yeah, I think they know.
And it starts with the letter M.
Mokey bird.
Ah yes, my favorite type of bird.
Yeah.
Guys, I'm cheating right now because instead of drinking alcohol...
Guys, I don't want...
I don't know.
I don't want to feel like an alcoholic if I'm drinking for the third time of the week.
Like...
A week?
What else have you been doing?
No, like, every time we've done massage, I was drinking.
And I'm like, do I really want to drink again?
That's...
That's three weeks.
That's not three times this week.
Okay, but it's...
I usually don't drink that much per, like, year.
So...
Oh, okay.
That's fair.
So, sorry.
Third time in a week.
Wait, no.
Week at 10.
I'm so tired.
She doesn't...
She doesn't need the alcohol, you guys.
She's already drunk.
Guys, I don't need the alcohol.
I'm already...
Mentally, I'm already there.
Like...
I'm drinking bubble tea instead.
Yeah, we're both.
That sounds good.
What can I do?
I got the honey, um, milk green tea.
Can I have a sip?
Yeah.
Want me to regurgitate it to you like a bird?
Ahhhh.
That's how cats do it too, right?
Oh my god, wait, don't remind me of birds.
I know.
I cried earlier.
I watched...
So, there's this like...
There's this eagle couple that I've been watching.
Yeah.
And they've had a nest for 20 years.
Yeah?
What?
So, you're like...
You're like basically a creep.
Like a little creeper.
Watching them in the...
Like in a corner.
Yeah.
Okay.
And they've had this nest for 20 years.
And then, like, just the other day, there was a really bad storm and their nest fell.
They can just...
But can't they just make a new...
Wait, are the eggs okay?
Their nest was for...
No, the eggs, they all died.
How do you know?
Because it's like a...
It's like a...
It's like a bald eagle.
Oh.
Couple.
And so, they're like...
Protected by this...
Wait, why didn't they stop it?
I'm bringing the mood down here.
Wait, so like, why didn't they stop it?
Why did they get involved?
Because it's like...
You can't get involved in nature.
Why not?
Because, that's like, you know, that's...
I don't know.
I think they're bad people.
I think they're bad people!
Yeah, exactly.
Why didn't they just...
You know, just get out of that camera and just, you know, hold the nest together.
Hold the nest out.
They should have put some little, like, what's it called?
Super glue.
Come on.
Super glue the nest.
And I'm like, wow, my nest is so strong.
It hasn't been broken since in 20 years.
It was so sad, too, because the bird, one of them was, like, laying in the nest.
And then you just watch her go down.
What?
You watched the bird?
Would you watch it live if the bird just go down with the nest?
Yeah, she was okay, though.
But then they, like, came back and they were, like, looking at where the nest was supposed to be.
And they were, like, all sad.
Oh, wait, how long do bald eagles live anyway?
So it's been there for 20 years, right?
How long do bald...
Because if they're about, you know, they're at the end of their lifespan, then this should be...
It should be fine.
They, you know, they have time for them to go through...
20 to 30 years.
So, like, wait in the world, it's around 20 years.
So, like, maybe that's why they didn't intervene.
Because they're like, well, they've had a good 20 years, you know?
They live around 20 years.
So, like...
So, so everybody knows that if Doki is taking care of you and believes that you're at the end of your lifespan, she'll just give up on you.
Yeah, you've lived a good life.
I'm just saying, you've lived a good life.
I mean...
That's it, that's it for you.
Doki Bird says you're at your average lifespan.
Goodbye.
Yeah.
We need the space for something new.
We need that.
Um...
I'm thinking about them birds.
I was crying.
I saw I was crying earlier about it.
Oh my god, it was like, yeah, it's almost like, it's like that old couple in the Titanic.
Yeah.
I'll never let go.
She really didn't.
Yeah.
She went down with the nest.
Now, where was the husband in all of this?
Why wasn't he there?
Typical man behavior.
I know, right?
Didn't go down with her.
Like, I can't believe it.
He, I bet he was in a shelter with, in a different nest, too.
Don't say that!
They're loyal!
Why wasn't, why wasn't he there with her?
Coincidence?
Why wasn't he there?
Oh my god.
I'm saying, there was a huge storm and the husband isn't there to check on his wife during the biggest storm of their lives.
Of their lives.
The end of their lives.
The end of our lives.
At the end of their lives too.
I mean, they live around 20 years.
They're getting there.
What if it wasn't even a storm?
What if he was on the other side of the tree, like, shaking it?
He was just like, damn!
It's like, the last batch of eggs.
I can't go through another.
I can't...
He was like, this is the last one.
Now he can be a free bird.
No more kids.
Free meditated.
Bird-er.
That's what it is.
It's bird-er.
Oh my god, it's a bird of passion.
I was like, you guys are the worst and you're included with me.
No!
You're guilty by association.
I brought it up.
You know what?
I'll take this.
I'll take this one.
Alright, anyway.
Today we're playing the Dolores chapter.
But most likely we might not be finishing the Dolores chapter today.
Depending on how long... how it goes.
Because Min has to leave.
Um... has to leave at a set time.
So...
No.
If we don't finish it by then...
I guess we'll never finish the...
No!
They're gonna be so mad!
We'll see you next year.
The anniversary.
ever shoot.
Wait...
I think you can get it done.
Just be brave.
Oh my god!
But it's the longest and scariest chapter!
I don't think it's the scariest.
They said it's the scariest!
No!
We...
The bathroom one was the scariest.
We said the bathroom one?
No!
I said both of them are really...
I think like, apparently, like, the...
what was her name?
Lucy!
I had to get into dad mode.
I was like, what did the dad use today?
Lucy, where are you?
Lucy!
I think, like, the Lucy chapter is supposed to be more jump-scary, and then the Dolores chapter apparently is more psychological fear.
Oh, that's not scary.
So there's, like, more suspense.
You're not the one playing him.
I played Minecraft earlier, that's literally a horror game.
Oh, so scary, Minecraft.
You don't know the Kraken.
Excuse me, it's Craft Mine, not Minecraft.
Oh, yeah.
I played Craft Mine.
Oh, yeah?
I played the Jack Black game mode, which was very bad.
Oh, did you actually?
It was made for... it was actually made for kids.
Oh.
Alright.
I mean, that's the Minecraft movie.
It's supposed to be for kids.
That's the Minecraft movie.
Yeah.
You know the Minecraft movie is about to become the number one best-selling video game movie?
You know that?
Oh, what is it... what is it gonna be?
Mario?
Um, I think... wasn't Mario the best... I thought it was... I think it was Mario.
Okay.
Best-selling video game movie.
She stalling again?
Um, no, because you asked me a question, and I'm just trying to answer your question.
Like, yeah, it was Mario.
Right now, it's at seven... wait... it's at 720... million dollars.
Wait, I thought it made billions so far.
Oh, it's closer to a billion dollars already.
It's getting close to a billion dollars.
Wait, that's three days ago.
So it should be a billion dollars now.
A billion dollars?
A billion, bajillion, million dollars.
Why do you say it like that?
That's a lot of money.
Yeah!
See guys, I don't need alcohol to be stupid.
Okay, let's start.
I'm just mentally exhausted right now.
Okay.
Alright, let's...
That's the same as being drunk.
Yeah, honestly, yeah.
Alright, continue.
Alright, I remember the biggest issue is that we ran out of all materials and stuff for this game.
So, like, that's what I'm scared about.
I have zero meds.
I have zero meds and, uh, no lighters, but, like, a kajillion light bulbs.
Oh, I forgot.
I was like, oh my god, what the fuck is that?
I forgot that's the Holy Mary.
I have so many light bulbs.
Some light bulbs.
I don't know what to do with all of these light bulbs.
We can find more things.
Probably.
I hate this game.
Alright.
Where's Grandma?
I should have played Layers of Fear instead of Visage.
I should have said...
Layers of Fear is nothing.
Yeah, that's why I should have said Layers of Fear instead of Visage.
Oh...
Wait, someone said...
Oh!
Your reminder that the storage room in the basement exists with supplies.
Okay.
I guess I go there.
I think it also refreshes every...
After every chapter, no?
Does it?
What?
I don't know.
I've lost track.
I don't remember where.
Grandma.
How do I get there?
The basement?
Right here?
Oh.
Is it here?
Yes.
Because there's a...
To this...
Right?
Oh, here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where's the light?
Oh, there it is.
I forgot that...
Whoa.
Did that just turn on by itself?
Yeah.
Yeah, it did.
And I don't like that.
It might be the storage.
That does not make me happy.
That does not bring me joy.
Open the door.
See if it's the storage.
Is that the storage?
I don't remember.
I don't know.
No, it's locked.
I have no basement key.
Don't you have a basement key?
No.
Oh.
What's this?
Basement key.
Probably not.
What is it?
Basement key.
No, it's not.
Uh huh.
Oh.
Why is it so dark in here?
Yeah, why is it so dark?
Oh.
Hey!
It's the storage!
Exactly!
Exactly what I said!
No, it's not the storage.
Oh, look it's a comic book page.
Oh.
The neighbors page?
What the hell is that about?
I don't fucking know.
That's not the...
This is not the storage area, you liar.
I don't even have...
Yes, it is.
Oh, you got a chainsaw.
It literally is...
Chainsaw.
Is someone walking above us?
I don't know.
No.
Where's the light?
Is this the light for this?
No, is this the light?
We're not even in the chapter.
Nothing can hurt us right now, right?
I don't know.
I don't know if I'm not okay.
I'm not okay right now.
Maybe you do need the alcohol.
Do you have any?
Yeah, I do.
It's always there.
Just in case of emergency.
I like that people said to go to the storage, but did not tell us where it is.
Yeah, this is your fault.
People who told me to go here.
What?
What's wrong?
The light turned off, so I guess I don't go there no more.
We're back upstairs?
We're back upstairs.
I'm like not... I'm so stressed out right now.
Don't be stressed.
What's that?
I don't know.
Or even is it a grandma story?
I don't know why it's a jam.
Nothing's going on.
Nothing's happening.
You're just going in circles now.
I don't.
I'm so confused.
If you go to the left, you get to the TV room.
See?
They're there.
There's a TV room.
Maybe there's something over here.
Oh, that's the laundry room.
This is the laundry room.
That's Dad's office room.
That's the office room.
Or actually... Oh wait, no.
The key to that room was in Dad's office room.
It's locked.
Is this the storage room?
No.
It's a boiler room?
What is that?
Oh, man.
I don't know.
Okay, just start the story then.
No!
Wait, wait.
What about that door right there?
This door?
No, that one.
Oh, wait.
There's the storage room.
The
storage!
Check the rest of the room!
Storage!
We have to look around.
What's that sound?
What do you mean?
You hear that?
What was that?
Stop!
Why am I hearing him whispering?
I just gotta out-ghost him.
Can we just edit...
Can we just do a satsidan?
Let's just go back upstairs and start the game.
Oh, hey, there's a video.
Oh, you got tape!
Yeah.
They said...
Oh, yeah.
They said there's something I didn't save.
They said it would be stored.
Oh, my god.
Why did I do that?
This is the spooky part.
Is this the grandma?
No, I haven't done anything yet.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
It's just not okay right now.
Oh, what the fuck?
I TP'd.
I don't want to get out of here.
It's inside the room with the tag on the door handle.
Oh, the one that...
I think we need a key to go in that, no?
Yeah, we don't have dad's study room.
Isn't it in his...
No, I think...
No, it's...
No, this is...
This starts the chapter.
No, I think...
No, the key was in the study on the second floor.
Huh?
At least that was what it said in the...
I might be making shit up.
I don't know, actually.
I don't know anymore.
It just...
You know the study?
Right there?
Yeah.
See if there's a key in here.
I don't know if there is or not.
If not, it might be fine.
Maybe there's stuff in here.
Maybe dad gave me...
Forgot...
Oh, oh, oh!
There is!
See, see, see, see, see!
Oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, my God!
I can finally have meds!
Oh!
Now you can go back downstairs.
Into the basement.
Okay.
I haven't even started the chapter yet.
Well, that's the better part.
Then it's good that you're getting all the stuff before you start the chapter.
Nope, turn around.
There you go.
Yippee!
How about like... How about like, you know...
This is not the storage!
This is the electric room!
The electric room!
Yeah!
The light!
Okay, now find things.
There's something.
Oh god, what are you looking around for?
Oh my god, that's a floating lighter.
That was a floating... yeah.
What's that?
What?
A strange frame?
I don't know, I'm keeping it though.
It's mine now.
What's that?
Nothing?
That's nothing.
Hey, that's just lights.
There was only a lighter in here?
Yeah, there was just one lighter.
I guess that's better than nothing, but...
I need meds!
Where's the meds?
I'm gonna go crazy!
I'm gonna go booga booga!
I...
The stool?
I don't need the stool!
I got two lighters!
What am I gonna do with two?
Yay!
Yay, two lighters!
What am I gonna do with two lighters?
I need meds!
You can now start the story.
That's what you need to do.
No, I need...
I cannot just start the story, man.
What if she...
Yes, you can!
Not three lighters!
Three lighters!
Oh my god!
And a candle!
There's a candle!
Dual-wielding?
Dual-wielding lighters!
Where are the meds?!
Where are the crazy people?!
Oh, more candles!
Oh, never mind.
Are the...
I thought those were candles.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Why do the lights keep turning off by themselves?
Okay, look.
There's another tape.
What's that say?
Oh, no.
Addiction.
Oh, addiction.
I think it says abduction.
Abduction.
We're...
Child...
Kidnapper?
Oh!
Um...
Are there...
Meds here?
Oh, did that door just close?
I'm gonna pretend...
Let's just go upstairs and start the story.
But what about my meds?!
You could light that candle.
Seriously.
Yeah, but the candle only works if...
I have like...
Uh...
Like a place to put them on.
Oh.
Like, it doesn't matter unless I have...
I don't understand!
I thought this is a crazy house!
Oh wait, that's where you put the VHS tape.
Yeah.
Okay, let's see.
I'll just keep them.
We have so many.
I'll just hold on to it for now.
It doesn't really matter.
Oh, they can be stored there if you wanna store them.
Yeah, but it's just gonna be in my inventory forever anyway, so does it really matter?
What if you have too many tapes and you find so many medicines all in one?
Oh my god, look how...
Okay, they're not...
Look at my inventory here.
You're gonna find...
6, 9, 12...
You're gonna find 20 medicines.
I don't understand.
Why can't I just eat these pills?
It's just sitting there!
Oh, do you think all pills are the same?
Yes.
Alright, start the story.
Start the story!
Don't keep her!
No, no, wait.
Wait a minute.
I can still believe a little bit.
Maybe?
Oh!
Is that some right there?
No, that's not the right pills.
I don't understand.
I can't...
Can't I just have...
Oh, but I thought any pills were good pills.
I have q-tips.
You can actually examine the q-tips?
Yeah, yeah.
Maybe there's some pills in there.
They're called q-creen.
Mister.
Wow.
I'm starting the...
How's the game volume, everybody?
I'm starting the hardest chapter with no pills!
I can't do this!
Maybe...
Maybe parrot...
Why do they have all these candles in the world?!
This...
This mom...
Did mom store any in there?
There's gotta be pills in there.
Okay, there's gotta be...
Oh my god.
They must be holding out on me.
There's no way...
You actually sound like an addict right now.
What was that?
Just a stupid doll.
It doesn't matter.
I don't understand.
I...
There's another...
There's another lighter.
There's so many lighters in the world.
Maybe you don't need pills this chapter.
No, I...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, there's alcohol though.
Oh, mommy was keeping alcohol in the drawer.
Don't understand.
There's so many.
There's like so many...
Oh my god.
Those shoes actually freaked me out.
Maybe...
I'll be right back.
I'm gonna go...
No, wait, wait.
I'll be right back.
Where are you going?
Where...
I'm gonna go get some more water so I can take some medicine.
Oh, okay.
Oh, did your food arrive?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Yeah, so I'm gonna get that and get water and medicine.
I'll be back.
No, I won't be so long.
Okay, bye.
Guys...
Oh, oh!
Oh my god, that's my lighter.
Oh!
That's my lighter floating towards me.
Oh my god.
I just had lots of goosebumps from the floating lighter that floated towards me.
Guys...
Where are the other meds?
Where are they?
I don't understand.
Shouldn't there be more meds?
I don't understand!
Where are all the meds?
Yeah, but there's so many lighters!
There's so many lighters, yet zero meds.
I...
There's...
There's no way...
There's no way we have a shortage.
There's no way we have a shortage of fucking...
Oh my god.
There's no way.
I refuse to believe we have a shortage.
Why is there still more lighters?!
Everywhere go!
It's a fucking lighter!
I'm just still wielding lighters at this point!
I'm just gonna put this guy over here.
I don't care.
I have so many lighters and candles.
I don't care anymore.
I...
There's so many!
I can't...
I'm gonna pause.
I found...
I found another lighter!
I found three more lighters!
But yet not a single fucking medication bottle!
I don't...
Well...
Um...
Sounds like you just gotta use candles then.
Instead of...
Medic...
Why are you paused?
Come on!
Let's go!
Chop chop!
Remember I gotta leave early!
Let's go!
I got a burrito.
Can I just give you my save file?
I did not do this for charity!
Oh no!
But you're more of a support!
Note to self, when I...
Whenever I do a charity stream, I'm not putting...
Or this game...
Or...
On the list!
Oh!
A Dolores chapter!
Yeah!
Where do I go?
Um...
Let me not read the walkthrough I have pulled up.
Yeah!
Don't worry!
We're not cheating!
I don't know where to go!
Where do I go?
So we...
So it looks like there's gonna be mirrors we have to break throughout the house.
Oh, come on!
Oh, is it this one?
It has a mirror on it.
Does it?
Oh, maybe.
Oh!
Eugh!
I don't understand.
I...
I think you're in the right spot!
There's a key with it.
So we gotta find another key?
Is there another room with a mirror on it?
Hmm...
Oh, there's another room.
Wait, no.
That's the same room.
Oh!
That's literally the same room that I just unlocked.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Maybe you can loop the ghost.
I don't understand.
Um...
Sis...
Uh...
So we gotta find a sledgehammer somewhere.
I don't understand.
Did I miss the sledgehammer on here?
Did I just not look down?
I don't understand.
What about the door right behind you?
It's just...
The door...
The door behind...
Nope, not that one.
Nope, that one right there.
That door.
I can't open it.
I don't understand.
Sledgehammer!
Where is the sledgehammer?
Maybe go try...
Where would a sledgehammer be?
Maybe the garage.
Oh, but...
How do I get to the garage?
Oh, yeah.
It was locked wasn't it?
Uh...
Mom...
What's that?
Oh!
Probably need jean pockets.
I don't have jean pockets.
You might.
You have jean pockets.
I...
I don't know.
Uh, go to your...
Go to...
Your closet.
What?
That's...
Where are you going?
That's a girl.
That's...
No, I don't think the daughter's gonna have the...
Keys.
The parents' room.
The parents' room!
I'm freaking out.
Stop freaking out!
I don't...
It's fine.
I'm not fine.
Oh, there's no jeans!
Right there!
On the ground.
Jeans.
No?
Check the closet.
But there's nothing going on, Doki!
Nothing happening!
There's nothing here!
Are those cookies in the closet?
I don't know.
Oh, candles.
I'm somehow more useless when I'm sober.
I... I didn't think it was possible.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'll take a drink.
Okay.
Yeah.
I definitely... You know, I definitely need... I definitely need a drink.
I hate that.
So what do I do next?
We're looking for the key!
It said... Wait, is that what the note said?
You clicked it so fast, I couldn't even read.
I couldn't.
I was too sober to read.
I... I was... I was too... I was too sober to read.
Like, I just saw jeans.
That's all I saw.
I saw jeans.
I don't know what it just says.
It could be in my jeans.
In my jeans?
Well, maybe check your... check your inventory.
Maybe it's been in your pocket this whole time.
Oh, no.
There were no jeans in my inventory.
No, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no, no!
Jeans.
What do I do?
I open two doors!
You keep playing the game.
What do I do?
But where do I go?
Unpause!
I don't go!
We're looking for the keys!
But where's the key?
In the jeans!
But where's the jeans?
We have to look!
Yes, but where do I look?
Check your inventory.
I dare you.
Okay, okay, okay.
It's not in my... look, look, look.
It just says...
It's probably in the laundry room!
In the laundry room!
You literally...
It's one thing we both forgot about, I guess.
Oh my god.
Literally, the answer was right there for you.
Oh, you could light that.
I know.
Oops.
This is why you kept eating all your pills and then cried about it.
I wouldn't have cried about it if you gave me better direction.
Turn around.
There you go.
Don't.
Turn around.
Wait, is that the laundry room?
No, it's not in the closet!
What is it?
Towards the TV!
Go towards the TV.
We were just there!
This is the laundry room.
Yes.
No, that's the fridge.
Oh, wait.
I thought this was the laundry room.
No, it's not.
Oh, now I don't know.
Oh my god.
You don't even know where it is.
Nah, I don't know.
Is this it?
No.
Is this the laundry room?
Oh, now that's the bathroom...
Oh...
Oh, that's the toilet.
Oh no, that's the bathroom.
Where is the...
Where is the?
Where do people do laundry?
Laundry.
Where people do laundry.
No, this is the garage.
Laundry, where?
Why are you saying it like that?
Where is the laundry room?
I thought it was that one room.
Oh, it's next to the kitchen.
Oh.
It's not downstairs.
Wait a minute.
I guess not.
There you go.
Next to the kitchen.
This is kitchen.
Kitchen.
Oh, no.
This is the dining room.
Then the kitchen is here.
Kitchen here.
And then laundry room is probably over here.
What?
Yeah.
Yippee!
Okay.
And your jeans.
My jeans.
Any jeans?
Where's the jeans?
My jeans.
You got all the recessive jeans.
Jeans where?
Check inside.
Oh, it's in the dryer.
Oh, fuck.
The elderly are really scary.
What if she's hiding in there?
She's like, I can't wait for Dolores to say her famous thing.
She's like, hello, sweetie.
I'm going to Dolores you.
I'm just like, you want a little crackery?
I want a little crackery.
Garage.
Do you want a little... Wait, how...
What did I get pills?
What did I...
How did these pills get in my head?
Toki, I told you.
You had them this whole time.
You have a problem, Toki.
I don't even know when these pills showed up in my head.
It just like appeared out of nowhere.
Well, put them in your inventory before you accidentally eat them.
Okay, right.
You're right.
That's so true.
As she doesn't do that.
Whoops, I...
Okay, there we go.
My dual wielding lighters.
Wait, did you just throw them away?
No, I put them in the...
Wait.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oop.
Why doesn't it work?
It's because it's not broken.
Why is it not around?
Yeah.
Hello?
Maybe it's inside.
Oh.
Oh, see ya.
Okay.
Alright, find a sledgehammer.
Is this a sledgehammer?
Looks like it.
Oh, there...
No, that's a rake.
Nope, that's a rake.
Is that a sledgehammer?
Is this a butterfly?
I'm here to do butterfly.
I think the colors in the sky.
I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I.
Okay, then, lock that.
Where's the, where's the hammer?
What if Dolores comes over and just starts hitting me?
Wait, oh, it says it's inside the car.
But... In the car?
Something's not right.
My walkthrough is wrong.
It's different.
There's nothing in here.
Oh!
Like I said... Oh, God!
Okay, maybe it's upstairs.
Oh, my... walkthrough is wrong.
I have no idea now.
Everything is different.
I'm completely lost.
Look at my... my... my six lighter.
It says... Oh, garage room.
Where does this go?
Oh, it goes here.
Wait, what?
Why is... why are there so many ways to get to the garage?
Oh, hi.
Yeah.
Uh... Oh, it says you didn't start the chapter.
I did.
But we did.
Yeah, we did.
I picked up the key with the mirror.
I picked it up.
Maybe we have to find the mirror first.
Maybe... go back to the room with the mirrors.
But I went through there.
There was nothing there.
It just looped me.
They were just like, surprised.
And I was like, hello.
Hello, good sir.
Let's see.
It's this one.
Look.
We have to go find a mirror.
Hold on.
Let's go in.
Is there like anything that we can... It's jammed.
Can we...
Can we take off the thing off the mirror?
Oh, yeah.
See, there's a sound coming from it.
Oh.
Hello.
Hello?
Okay.
Now we think we can go.
Mirror, mirror.
What's that sound?
Oh, it's saved.
Oh, I started the chapter.
Oh, wow.
Whoa.
Who would've thunk?
We didn't do the thing.
I know.
Hello.
I don't know if you want to keep taking these off.
Oh.
Hello?
What's going on?
What's going on over there?
Hello?
Knock, knock.
Oh, my God.
Are you going to die here?
Oh, it's another mirror.
Oh.
That's another mirror.
Oh, the mirror seems to show a room in the house.
Where's... Where's that?
Where is that?
I don't know.
I'm going to use the bathroom.
Oh, my God.
We just started.
There she goes.
Okay.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
This feels like Mint is playing critically acclaimed lit game Lifeline.
But Doki is less responsive real.
I... I... I got up... I got a...
A walkthrough because...
I want to try and finish the chapter today, but I don't think that's happening.
She's just making it harder on herself, no?
Because if she doesn't finish the chapter today, she's going to have to keep doing it.
She's going to have to play it again.
My burrito is okay.
I just... I wanted a trash burrito.
So I got Taco Bell because I don't...
You guys, sorry if I'm a little...
If I'm a little...
I don't feel very well right now.
I'm eating so that I can take some pain in my bishops.
Tell us what kind of burrito.
It's a five layer burrito from Taco Bell.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
Oh, hi.
Okay.
I'm okay now.
I'm okay.
I'm...
I don't know.
We went around the whole house.
I mean, to be right around the whole house without starting the chapter.
But don't we have to get the sledgehammer?
Do we have to?
Oh, wait.
After...
So, yeah.
We do have to go get the sledgehammer.
Because it says the first mirror will be found on the second floor near the sun's room.
Oh, okay.
And then...
Okay, now we can go to the garage.
I think now.
Oh.
Ew.
Why is our roof so dusty, crusty?
Doki Bird is taking her first breaths as a baby.
Oh, maybe not.
There's supposed to be a car alarm going off.
Okay, I think we gotta go find that room.
I mean, the attic's up here, right?
Oh.
Is...
No.
I don't know, actually.
We need to find the room first.
Okay.
Maybe here.
Where...
Was a rocking chair?
I don't remember any chair that was rocking.
There isn't a pier.
There's...
Where would it be rocking?
Maybe I could look up and there'd be an attic above me?
I don't think you go to the attic yet.
I think we need to find the rocking chair.
Yeah.
Yeah, but we're rocking chair.
Where would things start rocking?
Grandma's room?
Where the hell is grandma's room?
Grandma has her own special little room.
Oh, wait.
Is that it?
Rocking?
Oh!
Turn around!
Come on.
I hear it.
Where are you going?
Go...
Turn around!
Go back in that room!
I don't wanna go back.
I can.
Go back in there!
I don't wanna go back.
Take another drink and then go back in there.
I just...
I don't wanna go back.
Now, where are you going?
I don't know where to go.
You go into that room!
Oh my god!
Now... Check that door.
It's jammed.
I hear it though.
Don't you guys... Maybe go upstairs.
Try upstairs.
It's in the parents room maybe.
Why are you looking at... I don't know.
There's an attic maybe?
Just follow the sounds.
You hear it creaking, right?
I do, but I'm pretending I don't.
Well, that's gonna make this game a lot longer.
That's the attic.
Yeah, but I don't think we're going there yet.
How do we... No, it says it's out of reach.
Oh.
Oh, you got another one of those freaky dolls.
The lights in my room just flickered.
Just follow him.
He's telling you where to go!
Is he a good man?
Wait,
what?
That's a candle room.
Where candle spot.
Where did I fall?
Where did you put your candle at?
In detail.
Where did he go?
I don't think he went down here.
I think he went down the hallway.
Vroom?
No.
No vroom?
No, I think you gotta go follow him.
Where did he go?
I think he turned to the right.
I went down there.
Hello, sir?
Oh, there he is.
Sir, where are you?
I'm gonna go follow that way.
Where are you going?
Keep following him.
Maybe.
What was that sound?
Oh, the lights don't work.
Oh, the lights not working.
You can fix it, right?
Oh, look at that.
What is that?
Yoink.
Is that the husband?
That's grandpa.
I told you the elderly is scary.
Hey, what's this for?
Did you ever see that movie about the...
The what?
The kids that went to their grandparents' house and then the grandma was naked and climbing under around the house?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Because it was by M.
Night Shyamalan.
Was it?
Yeah, it was about how like the...
The...
Where am I?
It was about...
Wait, I should save.
It was about like, um...
These kids try to visit their grandparents and then like they haven't seen...
The kids haven't seen their grandparents in a long time since they were children or whatever.
So they didn't know how they actually looked like.
And then it like the 2 grandparents were actually like, from the insane asylum or something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then, like, they ate the grandparents or killed... I don't know, they ate the original grandparents or killed them?
They ate them?
Wait, why is it going back up?
Am I banished?
Why does it sound like it's moaning?
Just, I think, walk.
Oh, it's because, like, the parents didn't know because, like, the dad's not in the picture anymore.
And then the mom was like, go see your mommy and daddy.
And then the mom was like, oh, hey, there's my rocking chair.
I don't like that.
Oh, try going through.
Oh, oh, hey, things are nicer now.
That's cool.
Oh, things are not nicer now.
What is that?
That's a ghost.
It's like a ghost.
A good, good, good.
Pieces.
Oh, the baby's missing.
No, I think it's the little dangly thing.
Oh.
Oh, the baby's missing.
Oh, I think the baby's also missing.
Hello?
I used... and even though it can be stored in the absorb...
...to find those storage spaces.
Okay.
So maybe you don't need meds.
Oh.
I don't know about that.
What?
Oh, oh.
There's so many.
It's become very hard to pinpoint the exact disorder.
They tell me she's got symptoms of schizophrenia, bipolar disorder...
Y'all have schizophrenia.
Wow.
She got a lot of things wrong with her.
Yeah.
Oh, she's crying.
I think you should seek a second opinion.
I know, you're right.
They just tell people they have schizophrenia...
...because they just don't want to deal with them.
It's like hysteria, remember?
Schizophrenia is just like when they told women they were hysterical.
It's not real.
Those voices just tell me...
Everyone has voices in their heads.
Yeah, everybody does.
Yeah, see?
Sometimes you have multiple voices.
I've never...
I'm not even here.
I've never been here.
Okay.
Yeah, the more the merrier.
The more voices you hear.
The more friends you have.
Yeah, who's mint?
Oh.
What do I...
Um, what do you do?
It's a music box symbol.
It's locked.
What do I...
Um...
I'm stuck here.
What, is it really that bad to be stuck here?
Oh, does that have a code or anything?
I don't know.
Um...
There's more code.
Five.
There's more.
Three.
And then there's more...
What do the numbers say, mint?
They're the lotto numbers.
What do they say?
Actually, that's what my grandma did.
She had binders and binders and binders full of lotto numbers.
Because she thought she could predict what the next lotto number would be.
Did she win?
Do you think my grandma...
Do you think my grandma ever won the lottery?
Maybe she, like, buried it.
One day you're gonna find a note.
You're gonna find a note that she had the lotto numbers.
Mint.
Only you understood.
Use the numbers.
In 20 years, you're gonna find a piece of paper.
That will lead you to the numbers.
The one piece.
The numbers.
What do they mean?
Oh, wait.
I have...
What do they mean?
What the...
Oh.
Wait, what?
I don't like that.
Oh, like the full...
I really don't like that.
Who is that?
I don't know.
But there are a bunch of paintings.
Did you look through the whole thing?
Did you look to the left?
Yeah.
Okay.
I did.
Yeah.
Oh, what are there?
Oh.
Hello.
Okay.
Are there more?
What do the numbers mean?
You have two holes for each of your eyes.
So you can look at once.
Whoa.
Any others?
No, those are all the holes.
If there's a hole...
Two holes.
It looks like something is missing.
A shoe?
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
The other shoe.
I'm going to dress up like her.
Oh, my God.
Granny's little outfit.
What'd you do?
I'm going to dress up like her.
You were so ugly.
You broke the mirror.
They hated the outfit.
Wait.
Granny's outfit is gone.
The door is open.
All right.
Keep going, baby.
I thought you said you liked this house.
I don't like this house no more.
Oh.
Did you see that?
Yeah.
Is that her?
Oh, it won't light up.
Is she down there?
Granny.
Grandma.
Oh.
I think that's her.
Grandma.
Granny.
What do the numbers mean, Grandma?
Oh, she's right behind.
I said look behind.
Oh.
Hello?
You're kind of crazy.
Stand in the light for a second.
I got the pills.
Or I take the pills.
Who knows?
Who cares?
Whatever.
Okay.
I got the pills.
All right.
So that's one.
Okay.
So Granny is now going to kill me.
Potentially.
Oh, look.
There's the blood trail.
Oh, no.
Oh.
All right.
That's not radical at all.
Keep...
Yep.
Follow up.
Follow that.
Follow it.
That's not cool.
I don't think that's cool, Granny.
I think it is pretty radical in a literal sense.
I don't think it is.
Well, your Granny brings a pool of oil.
Whoa.
Is it?
Is it like an intestine?
Yes, it is.
Whoa.
That's not cool no more, Granny.
That's not cool, Granny.
Oh, you're going to go in there.
Don't you hate it when your Granny gift leads you to the trail of blood into a long intestine?
We're going back into the womb.
Oh, no.
Oh, this is what it looks like.
I remember.
Oh, yeah?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I think your mom took too much...
Oh, wait.
That's the tar, man.
Yeah.
I think your mom took too much...
Too much zinc.
Zinc.
Wait, where you are?
Wait, what?
I don't know.
Look around.
I'm looking.
Keep looking.
Look where the tar, man, went.
What here?
Turn on the light.
Oh, that is...
Oh.
Oh, you have to crouch.
The gamers don't look down.
Yeah, yeah.
You didn't look down, either.
I'm not playing the game.
Hello.
Zinc, does that to you?
I don't think so.
You don't know that.
You don't remember what it was like in the womb.
Hello.
There's the mirror.
There's the mirrors.
Happy things happen in the mirror, right?
That's a lot of mirrors.
Do we have to break all of these?
Yeah.
I don't think I can.
Oh, hello.
Grandma.
G-Ma.
Happy things happen in the mirror.
Look, granny wants to see me.
Hello?
They say that the mirror is a portal to another world.
The spiritual world.
Oh, I see her.
There she is.
Oh, she ripped her hair out.
Do you see that?
Uh, uh...
Yeah.
She was a little...
I kind of.
Wait.
So, like, your portal leads to other grannies?
Oh, my.
I think she's gonna jump at you.
I know.
I know she is.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
Oh.
YouTube, don't look.
It's not what you think.
Maybe she's getting raptured.
And it stopped midway.
The rapture is buffering.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They had to download.
Download more.
Downloading more RAM.
Is she looking at you?
Yeah.
What do you do here?
Is there anything around, like, behind you?
I think you just keep looking until something...
Until she gets closer and closer.
And then she goes, ooga-booga-booga.
Icky-booga-booga!
Come on, granny.
It's ooga-booga time.
Hello?
Oh.
Did she get closer?
There she is again.
Uh, no.
She looks about the same.
She looks like Groot from here.
Okay.
Turn around.
Oh, she wanted me to turn around.
Ah!
I actually...
I actually backed up.
Me too!
Oh, my...
Oh, I don't want to go into that room.
I feel more safe up here.
Really?
I think you should go in.
Oh, fuck.
I need to breathe out.
After that.
Oh, my God.
I think granny level is the worst one.
What?
It's because...
It's because they're old.
Oh.
Old people are kind of freaky.
Yeah.
They have nothing to lose.
Exactly.
They're more likely to run at you naked.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're, like, more comfortable in their own skin, too.
It's also just freaky, like...
I don't know.
Like, I think they're creepier than children.
They're, like...
Who's breathing?
Might want to follow.
Don't make those sounds.
Don't keep birds.
Wait, the door is unjammed.
Wait, is that another mirror?
We have to break right there.
Oh.
Now you can go get the...
Now go to the garage.
No, but this door opened.
Yeah, but go to the garage because we gotta get the...
Oh, look.
Look at the door.
Over there.
Yeah.
It looks like the loading screen.
Oh, it does.
Don't clip that audio, everybody.
What?
Don't take advantage of her.
I'm in a vulnerable place right now.
She's in a vulnerable place right now.
I'm so vulnerable.
Do I go downstairs?
Do I get my hat?
Yeah, go to the garage.
Now we're gonna get the sledgehammer.
You'll feel safer with that.
See, see.
I got it.
I could go...
I could go smashy, smashy.
I know.
There's new around here.
Oh, you're talking about that kind of smash.
Smashy, smashy.
Smash or pass.
Grandma edition.
Would you smash that grandma?
I mean, she must have a lot of experience if you think about it.
Again, old people don't have anything to lose.
That's why there's more STDs in retirement homes.
You love that fact.
You bring up that fact whenever you can.
No, it's not true.
It just...
It was my segue.
It was a good segue.
Hey, any car people.
What kind of car is this?
If you have...
If you have a granny in a retirement home, you know she's getting some right now.
Can you turn off the alarm or...
No, we'll just leave there for comfort.
Oh, wait.
My inventory is full?
No, they can't do that to me.
I told you.
They can't do that to me.
I told you this day would happen.
They can't.
No.
No, they can't.
They can't.
They can't just...
Do you need all three lighters?
Yes, yes, I do.
Wait, no.
No.
Oh, I don't need the camera.
I don't keep the camera.
What if it's not...
What if it's like dark?
Why can't you store those things?
Oh.
Um...
Wait, how do I...
What do I do?
I think Dolores is coming.
Don't say that.
I'm trying to drop this item, but I can't drop it.
I can't drop it.
Why can't I drop it?
I don't understand.
I...
Okay, I drop this.
And then...
Okay.
I put this in.
And then...
I put this away.
I put this in.
Can we do this not here?
No.
There you go.
Um...
I got it.
It's my comfort sound.
My grandmother lived in the villages for 10 years.
STD capital of the country.
Hey, she had a good time.
The villages.
Whoa!
And now I have the lighter.
Who's that?
Who was that?
Who went...
It was like a cow.
Grandma's a heifer.
Rawr.
Hello?
Why can't I...
I can still hear the car.
Why'd you leave that?
Because I can't put my...
It won't let me hold my lighter.
You're holding it right now.
I can't store this.
Okay, remember this.
Oh, this looks like it's important.
Remember this, guys.
Screenshot it.
Stop the camera.
Stop.
12.30.
1.45.
And what's the last one?
What's the last one?
Here you go.
Remember this.
8.20.
Okay.
Why can't I?
I need the lighter.
I'll be back for it.
Oh.
Okay.
Yup.
Alright.
Did you remember it?
Yeah, probably.
Oh.
Can you actually turn off the alarm?
I don't know.
I'm leaving it there for my comfort.
Okay.
It's like my happy place.
Isn't there a mirror here?
Doki is psychotic.
Right?
I think it's gone.
Remember we touched it?
No.
Just find another mirror.
Could be one of somewhere.
Right there!
Why is the inventory in this such ass?
I know.
I'm so confused.
It's so hard to...
Use.
Alright.
Is that your best cat?
Oh, wait.
What?
What is this?
Oh, what'd you...
Why'd you grab that?
I don't know.
I don't know what's going on.
Like...
I don't understand.
Why can't I just hold this?
And then...
I know!
Oh, I can't even light it up.
I can still hear the car!
Oh.
What is going on?
Look up!
Oh, it's just leaves.
Okay, we gotta do a puzzle.
Wait, but how do I know which painting goes for what?
Yeah.
Maybe they just need to match.
But what matches what?
Oh, wait.
See, there's some here too.
Oh, there's...
No, wait.
There's something above me.
How do I get there?
Maybe once you solve the puzzle.
Oh, but how do I get there?
Um, by solving the puzzle.
But...
How do I...
There's something above me?
Um...
How puzzles solve?
I don't know.
Figure it out.
Um...
Uh...
Which ones can you move?
Oh, see these?
I can move all of these.
So many portraits.
But there's three that need to go on the wall.
Oh.
There's something above me?
I don't think we can solve it just yet.
I feel like there's something above me.
I don't think we can solve it just yet though.
Okay.
Maybe?
I don't know.
I'm not okay right now.
Can I rotate this?
No.
Let me rotate.
What do you mean I'm a great backseater?
I can like put these photos up too.
Yeah.
I won't backseat.
I'm just gonna sit back and relax and watch then.
Conk, conk, conk.
I thought you were supposed to help.
Where's the assistance?
I'm helping.
I don't like these.
What's that beep?
Nothing happens.
Oh.
Why is granny not here?
Isn't it good that granny's not here?
Wait, where did my hammer go?
I dropped it.
Oh my god.
No way.
You dropped it and you can't find it.
I don't.
Where did my hammer go?
Uh-oh.
Where did I drop my hammer?
Toki, Toki.
Why did you drop it?
No, I didn't pick up the pain.
Oh, there it is.
There's a pattern?
What's the pattern?
There's no pattern.
Is it the numbers?
Like one...
Like how many things are in there?
Okay, so...
Sorry, I haven't been paying attention this whole time.
This.
What's the pattern?
Some of the pictures are repeated.
Go to the hallway.
This one is here.
And then they put it here.
And...
Someone said go to the parents' room.
Oh.
Okay.
What's in the parents' room?
Is it...
Oh.
What was in the parents' room?
Wasn't there that one lady that was repeated over and over and over again?
That one ghosty picture?
No, no, no.
It's like...
No?
Okay.
I think I vaguely remember what...
It was like guy with no face.
I remembered.
Oh, you know what?
Woman with no face.
I remember that one because that one freaked me out.
This face.
It was...
This one.
This one freaked me out.
So, I remembered it.
Okay.
Um...
And that one was like in the middle.
In the middle.
Oh,
they stored my sledgehammer.
They took my sledgehammer away.
They took it away.
Why'd they take it?
I literally went there so I could grab this painting.
Oh my god.
Wait, is it not on the floor?
You gotta take it from here?
They took my...
They took it away.
Wait, she has no face too.
Wait, I just got the same one.
Which one was it?
It was like right here.
And then...
This one.
They all don't have faces either.
No, but it was like just that one that had no face.
I remember.
You said the one with no face was in the middle.
I don't know what I'm talking about anymore.
I remember this was...
I don't remember.
I have no idea.
I would go back to the parents' room.
Go back to the parents' room!
I don't wanna go back.
You gotta go get the hammer anyway.
Come on, it's in the storage room.
You could probably brute force this, but...
Maybe it was this one?
I am of no help.
Then why didn't you remember?
Why didn't you remember?
I didn't know it was important!
I didn't know!
Why didn't you remember?
Everything!
Oh, that room!
Why didn't you look at the...
I didn't look at the people, no.
You should turn DVR on and then I'll rewind the VOD.
Imagine if I turn DVR on right now.
And then I'll rewind and go look at it.
I got you.
I'm a genius.
I know.
You're so smart.
Wait, let me finish.
Yeah!
No way!
It's rewind time.
Okay.
It's rewind.
Woo!
Rewind time!
Is it on?
No, wait, wait, wait.
Alright, it's on now.
I'm gonna say something really bad.
Rewind time!
Okay.
Where's the grandparents room?
We stopped time.
Alright.
Checking?
Look, I lost my... I lost my hammer, guys.
I'm rewind.
That's another Jack Black movie.
That's...
Okay.
Wait, is this the first hole or the second hole?
Okay, that's the second hole.
Okay, hold on.
The first hole!
Yeah.
Wait.
Uh...
I'm going...
I'm rewinding.
Yeah.
Rewinding.
Rewinding?
Okay, hold on.
Rewind.
Oh gosh.
Wasn't there like...
Wasn't there like two...
Like it was...
They're just the same paintings, right?
For both holes?
Okay.
It's...
How do I describe this?
Okay.
It's the...
It's...
How do I describe this?
The one that looks like Uboa.
And then the one that has...
The one that looks like what?
Uboa.
And then the one with...
The skull...
Crushed in.
And then the one that looks like...
The pinhead.
The fuck is...
Okay.
We're going to look at all the pinnings.
I'm closing rewind.
Uh...
Rewind time is...
Did you remember what the paintings look like?
Do you remember?
Yes!
Okay.
Rewind time is over.
Wait, hold on.
Let me look.
Let me look at the second.
Okay.
Yeah.
Uboa, Skull Crusher, Pinhead.
Okay.
We run time over.
All right.
Okay.
So we got... We got this one.
Right.
That's Uboa.
That's Uboa?
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
I don't know what the fuck that one was.
That one, that's not important.
Get rid of it.
We don't get it.
All right.
Okay.
That's Uboa.
The fuck is Uboa?
Now we need... Now we need the Skull Crusher.
Oh!
They're over there!
To the... That guy is Pinhead.
That's Pinhead?
Okay.
Yeah.
He's on the far... He's on the far right.
Okay.
And now we need Skull Crusher.
Go check for him.
Uh... Nope.
Not that.
Hmm.
I rotate this.
How do you rotate?
Oh, nope.
Throw it away.
We don't need it.
What's that?
I'm trying to pick it up.
Uh... Hmm.
Isn't it Pinhead the guy with all the pins in his head?
Wait.
Is that Skull Crusher?
That's Skull Crusher!
That one?
Yeah.
All right.
In the middle.
Oh!
We did it!
Yeah!
Let me grab my disc.
Oh, we're at the hospital.
Oh, that's what the beeping's been!
Oh!
Hello, Granny.
I'm here to pay you a visit.
Oh!
Wow.
Infusion bag.
Okay.
We gotta come back.
Aww.
Hahaha.
But we figured it out, so whatever.
Oh, it's like that new Thunderbolts movie where they turn into shadows.
What?
You know, there's like a trailer of the new Marvel movie and then he turned in...
No!
Why did I close the door on myself?
Oh my god, you slammed the door on yourself.
Um...
Leave!
What are you doing?
I don't think there's anything.
I don't know.
I just...
I just felt a little safe being in that room.
Yeah, that was a nice little break.
Not to climb back up.
Okay, this chapter is has to be the scariest chapter.
I'm not okay right now.
I'm actually not okay.
If your rewind is still on, just refresh and it'll stop.
It'll stop.
I'm not okay at the moment.
Wait, but...
We're fine.
I don't...
They took my hammer.
Who's here?
Oh my gosh, they're here!
They took my hammer.
How do I...
How do I get my stuff back?
Also, the door to the...
Is that the door to the basement?
The one that's all blocked up?
How do I get my hammer?
Pizza!
Wait, how do I get my hammer?
Open the door, open the door.
How do I get to the storage?
I don't know.
But maybe...
What are you trying to...
They're just a guest?
You trying to bludgeon them?
Wait, have I...
Have I broken that mirror yet?
Yeah, you broke that one.
Okay.
Oh, I have to go through the garage.
Wait, is that another mirror?
Yes, it is.
Oh, I haven't...
I already broke that.
Wait, what?
Oh, the doors are locked.
What's going on?
It's because they're annoyed about the alarm.
They don't want you to go anywhere until you turn off the car alarm.
Oh, is she about to kill you?
I think she's about to kill you.
Oh.
Wait, who was at the door?
Who was phone?
Beep, beep, beep.
We're back here.
Hello, Grandma.
Hello.
I think there's one in there too, by the way.
Yeah, but they took my hammer.
Yeah, and there's two more right here.
Oh my God, Doki.
Oh, who are you calling?
Wait, why'd you hang up?
They called me.
Who are you calling?
I don't know.
They called me first.
Wait, I didn't hear anything.
Did you?
You're going crazy.
It was flashing.
Oh, why didn't you wait?
Now there's babies here.
We got to deal with grandmas and babies.
There's so many things.
I think we missed the whatever the door was.
I can't get my hand
in the basement.
Yeah, actually, I don't know what to do.
How do I get to the basement?
There's a second door.
To the kitchen, no?
No, they locked it.
I can't smash anything.
Hey, later.
There's a soft lock?
I accidentally soft lock myself because I left the hammer in the store.
No.
Go through the kitchen.
We don't know how to get to the kitchen.
That's the issue.
How do we get to the kitchen?
There's got to be a way.
How do I get to the kitchen?
Here, keep going.
Turn around.
Keep going.
Keep going that way.
And then...
Next to the laundry?
Living room door?
Where's the living room door?
I don't know.
Just keep walking.
I'm so confused.
And try left.
This way.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, see?
We're here.
Okay, this is the laundry room.
Wait.
But which one's the basement door?
Isn't it not that one down there?
That's the basement door.
Wait, that's the basement door.
I...
I saw one.
It's impossible.
You can just...
I didn't mean this.
I can't do this now!
Last auto-save?
Latest auto-save?
Where were we?
Okay, let's try latest auto-save number four.
Wait, no.
Someone said go to the garage.
There was another door in there, though, but it was also locked up, you guys.
It was locked.
Locked, yeah.
There was a... it was locked up in there.
We saw it.
Mirror before the garage.
Okay.
The mirror behind the door by the garage.
Then I took my sledgehammer.
They took it.
Yeah, the one down here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This one.
Try this one.
Okay.
Wait, I never got here?
Oh, I thought you said that you couldn't.
Oh, I was like, did I go here before?
And you were like, yeah.
And I was like, okay.
I didn't say that.
I remember you said that.
Why are you blaming me?
Maybe there's like the voices in my head.
You were just, you went up to it.
And you were just like, oh, I've already been here.
No, no.
You were like, you've been here before.
And I was like, okay.
What?
I didn't want to say that.
Oh, yay, the basement.
Oh, we're in the basement.
Yay.
Okay, we didn't have to restart.
Everything's fine.
Everything is okay.
All right, go to storage.
Go to storage.
Where's the storage?
Um, remember to there.
Oh, yeah.
And it has a sign on it.
Yeah.
That says storage room.
There it is.
Nice.
All right, and there was a mirror right here.
Yippee.
Wait, where's the mirror?
Right there.
Yep.
Oh, okay.
All right.
All right, let's go.
Smash or pass?
Smash!
Yay!
Oh.
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody who helps with that.
Thank you, guys.
We appreciate it.
Yeah.
But I feel like we would have figured it out in the end anyway, but thanks, guys.
All right.
And then I know...
She was on the load menu.
Like, ready to...
Literally seconds away from pushing the button.
I don't know about that.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Wait, what do we do now?
Keep finding more mirrors.
I think you can leave through that door and then go smash the other mirrors.
Um...
Oh.
It doesn't open anymore.
Yeah.
Okay, we have...
Maybe in here?
Maybe there's another mirror in here?
No, that's our...
That's our light swap switches.
Yeah, but what if there's a mirror in front of it?
Why is it so noisy down there?
I'm confused.
Um...
Maybe...
Go in here?
No, that...
They locked us up.
Oh wait, can you...
Oh no, you can't go through the garage.
No, go...
Don't go up.
Go to...
Go around.
They locked us up.
Were we just here?
Yeah, but there's like the...
No.
Wait.
Whoa!
No.
Yes!
That might be our way in!
No.
Smash!
Move that bus!
No.
There has to be other ways.
Why are you so afraid of smashing the wall?
There has to be other...
It has...
You'd rather go down the dark hallway than smash the wall in the brightly lit room?
I have this, so...
Okay, then go down the hall.
I don't see if I can.
Yeah.
Go break the wall.
Okay.
She's afraid of commitment.
What's...
This is like the least scary thing.
To smash the wall.
Yeah, but like...
Maybe we're not supposed to go down here.
I think we are because we're...
...here.
Smash!
Maybe grandma's living in the walls.
Oh, she's in our walls?
Yeah.
And she's naked.
Granny needs a bath.
Oh, we're gonna...
It's time to give granny a little bath.
Oh, we're gonna go...
Yeah, I mean, she'll look at...
It's so dusty in here.
Oh, I don't like this place.
Man, I don't like it.
She's in our walls.
She's naked in our walls.
Oh.
What's this?
A second basement?
These people are so rich.
They have like three basements.
Wait, go back.
What are you doing?
I'm not gonna shoot myself.
That's where I kill them.
And then I just finish the job.
Wait, is that...
I think there's a hand.
I'm not gonna finish the job.
I think we have to.
Okay.
If I die, we end stream.
You know what?
I take that.
Now you have a gun to shoot, grandma.
This is just liar's bar.
What are you talking about?
Yeah.
All right.
Oh.
Game the gun at your head.
And there's six bullets.
Shall I take this Russian roulette?
Six shots.
Surely, surely I'll miss, guys.
Um.
What if they're all blanked?
They're all...
Yeah?
You wanna take the shot?
I like those odds.
Wait, drop it and see if you can quick save.
All right.
What if it's a minigame?
This is where the liar's bar comes in.
Suddenly, like a new game boots up.
I knew this was a bad hole.
Yeah.
How do we get out of here, guys?
Don't go towards the car.
Beep.
What if it's here?
Oh.
This probably leads to the kitchen.
How come I can't put this...
Okay, there you go.
Smashy.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Now I'm upstairs.
I hate this game.
Where are we?
Oh wait, I like this game now.
Oh my god.
I can't...
The car is...
I can't do it anymore.
I will leave.
I like this game.
Oh wait, there's the outside.
Oh.
With the right tool.
Yeah, let's try that.
I can't use that here.
Use the sledgehammer.
Come on.
No, it's jammed.
It doesn't...
I can't use that.
It's glass!
I need...
Yeah, there you go.
Yeah.
That's all I got.
That's all the strength I have.
The car alarm is giving me like, left for dead 2, like...
Bonk!
Do that to grandma.
Okay.
Well, obviously it wasn't here.
We need something to pry it open, but we're...
What the hell did you just throw?
I didn't throw anything.
Oh.
Wait, what did you hear?
Oh, I think...
I saw like a leaf fall from the...
I can't use this.
It won't let me use the crowbar.
No.
It's like a...
Richie thing.
The horde is incoming.
Okay.
Well, that's another mirror.
I'm gonna find another mirror.
Oh my god.
How many mirrors are in here?
There's a lot.
We saw how many.
Okay.
Yeah, use that.
Maybe go down towards the light area.
Yeah, over here.
Yeah, I was thinking maybe there's another mirror here.
There's probably one in the dark hallway.
That probably leads back up to the kitchen.
Because this is gonna be...
See, this one's gonna be all boarded up, no?
Oh, there's one in here.
There's...
It's the mirror right next to it.
Nice.
Wait, this leads outside.
I'm outside now.
See, this is nice.
This is nice.
I can live here.
It's like that Chillizart game that just came out.
Oh, yeah.
Wait.
What?
You're in the dark?
I'm...
What?
I'm outside.
Look, there's the sun.
What?
I don't think...
What sun?
Go to the light.
And I'm...
My eyes.
I'm back home.
Oh.
Looped you.
Oh, wait.
Silent Hilled me.
We're...
No, this is Britain.
Can't wait to get shanked.
What's it?
Wait.
Because there's a door open.
That little gate?
No.
No?
What?
There's gotta be something here.
Where do I go?
No.
No?
Uh...
Wait, it doesn't open like a normal door where you have to hold it?
No.
See?
Whack.
What the fuck is a crowbar?
Wait.
Oh, I think I saw...
Oh, just kidding.
I thought I saw it.
You saw this?
Yeah, I saw that.
You saw this little merry-go-round?
Yeah, I saw the merry-go-round.
Just yanked the metal bar from the...
Probably...
Like...
Rusted enough for it that you'd be able to do it.
Oh my god.
They just want you to have a moment of whimsy.
You should go down the slide.
No!
Oh!
I'm sad.
Go down the slide.
It'll make you feel better.
Yeah, you're right.
It would.
If I could, I'm too old for the slide.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
No.
I can't get over the last couple of steps.
It's so messed up.
Why would you get rid of my whimsy?
Why?
Why did I have one thing in life?
Oh, you missed.
You missed.
I can't have nothing.
The moment of whimsy starts clapping horses.
There's clapping horses.
Well, that horse is going crazy.
How'd you hit that one when you aim for the other one?
All right.
There's gotta be something here though, no?
It has to be like another mirror, right?
How do we get...
I don't know.
There's a ladder next to a mirror?
What the fuck?
Oh, it's going crazy.
Did I do that?
It says ride me.
Moment of whimsy.
It's the moment of whimsy time.
Oh, I did that.
You might have actually done that.
I'm like, is that a ghost?
I'm the ghost.
Oh wait, there's a ladder.
Exactly what people said.
I can't go...
I can't go up this ladder.
Oh.
Oh, it was just cosmetics, I guess.
Um, there has to be another mirror, I guess then, that we missed.
I just don't understand that because there's nothing that we can interact with at all, so I don't even know what to do.
Yeah, I'm so confused.
Nothing that...
Well, you're playing the game, I don't know.
Maybe there's something in here, just not touching it.
Why is it so dark?
Hello?
Don't stand in the dark for too long.
I see your brain!
Go back to the light!
I'm going back.
I'm back here.
It's still pretty red.
What happened?
Okay, we're back in the light.
Um, maybe there's one in the storage closet?
In the storage room?
Wait, they brought my hammer back.
Wait, I think there is actually.
This one?
Does that count?
Yeah, I hear...
It's making noises.
I think it counts.
I'm going to take my pills real quick.
I don't like that I can see my brain.
No, no, I don't think you...
No, you can't, you can't.
Don't waste your pills, don't waste your pills.
I see my brain!
Yeah, but it's not red.
Don't waste it.
But I see it.
Is it bad to see your brain?
Yeah.
I didn't even know you had one.
What if you put a candle right there?
And it'll light up the room.
I don't have a candle.
Oh.
You did.
Oh, never mind.
I lied.
But it's making sounds!
All the mirrors make sounds, no?
What are we missing?
The stool.
What's the stool for?
Oh, you might want to take your pills.
Oh, I see my brain.
It's like really red.
I don't like this no more.
It's not fun no more.
Your sanity is decreasing fast.
Oh my god, take your pills.
Okay, I'm okay.
There was a path in the park?
There was?
Where at?
No, there wasn't.
There might have been.
I'm so confused.
The gun?
Yeah, you could always do the gun.
I'm so confused.
Wait, there's a step here.
Where do I put the steps to?
I don't know.
I hate this level.
This level fucking sucks.
This is really obtuse.
Like, it's not linear at all.
Hold on.
I'll look.
Let's see.
This level fucking sucks.
Next to the wardrobe in the basement.
It's where...
There's a wardrobe in the...
Next to the wardrobe in the basement.
What wardrobe?
Did we get that one already?
Okay, so this is the park, right?
Yeah.
And then also, it just like randomly takes away your sledgehammer.
Like, I don't know.
Why does it do that?
Because I threw it away because I wanted to use my lighter.
Oh.
There's no...
There's no crowbar here.
Hold on.
I'm licking.
Uh...
Interact with the open grave.
There's a grave somewhere.
There's a fucking grave?!
Who died?!
In the park!
Why is there a grave in the park?
Yeah!
Why the fuck would you plant a grave with all the children here?
It's multi-use.
Someone said you need the compass, but I...
How do I...
I passed it?
Uh...
Wait, the compass...
Bro, my sanity is decreasing being in this park!
Why is my sanity decreasing in the park?
It's...
It's the whimsy!
Uh...
Hold on, I'm looking at where the crowbar is.
Um...
Use the crowbar.
Where do we get the crowbar?
Here, it's apparently...
Next to a wardrobe?
The fuck is a wardrobe?!
See, I said the wardrobe!
You don't even know where the wardrobe is!
I have no idea.
You read that from chat!
No, I read it from the...
From ScreenRant.com!
Okay, as if that makes it any better.
I literally read...
Even before I was like, the wardrobe, Doki, you have to go to the wardrobe in the basement!
Oh my god!
Oh, that's probably the one I was hearing.
That's...
There it is!
Yeah.
And...
Bush!
Oh, it's useless now.
What do you mean?
Oh my god, I'm in the dark.
Do this not in the...
Yeah, don't do that.
No, I'm trying to, but it won't let me store the thing!
Oh, I...
There's nothing in the...
Oh my god, I have no more pills.
I have no more pills.
It's fine, we'll make it through.
Once we know what to do, we'll be fast if we die.
The cat is gonna kill me!
She's gonna get me!
Just stay in the light!
I'm pill-less!
I have a lighter though.
I don't know why the lighters are useless.
That's so rude!
Oh!
Oh my god, god will save me, right?
We're crawling?
Can you use the lighter?
I'm going crazy.
I don't need this.
I need these.
I don't think you can go crazy in these areas.
Like these special areas.
So that's nice at least.
Okay, I have to go here.
I wish I put her in the home.
I told you to put Dolores in the home.
I told you.
I told you we should have put it down there.
Oh, you meant...
You said a home.
I thought you meant our home.
I told you she should have...
Where am I?
What the?
Oh, you went in a circle.
Why?
Maybe you're supposed to find the...
What am I supposed to do?
Hold on.
Just look around before you leave.
Is there like anything in here?
There's more crosses here.
Oh, look.
Happy Easter.
It's John.
John?
Who's John?
It's John.
Okay.
What's in here?
Oh, that's where they put John.
John!
Oh, pull that.
Pull that.
Pull the lever.
I'm trying to pull the lever.
But he won't let me pull.
Oh, crap.
Hello?
It's John Easter.
Oh, crank!
Crank is me!
Okay.
Ow, ow.
We're putting her in a hole.
Hold on.
Let me see what I can find.
There must be a lever in here.
I don't understand.
I don't...
Oh, but, uh...
I don't understand.
I don't...
Use the manual crank from the mirror one puzzle.
What?
The mirror...
The mirror one was...
Oh, there...
Oh, okay.
Remember in that room where we saw, like, the grandma lunge at us?
Apparently, there was a crank in there.
What?
I didn't...
I didn't pick up any crank.
What?
I'm gonna bring the mirror to the end of the hall.
I used the switch hammer to break...
Do we get soft locked?
No.
Take the plank to cross the floor.
Ah!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
All right.
This...
This guide sucks.
I'm leaving.
Where is a plank?
Apparently, there was one.
Oh my god.
Maybe you can...
That one right there.
This one?
Is that plank?
No, maybe...
Oh.
Why can't I pick you up?
Uh...
Below the stairs.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna fucking freak out.
You already are.
What about that?
There you go, there you go.
There's so much wood around me.
But it has to be the wood of God.
I have...
It's symbolism!
This was blessed by Jesus almighty to let me cross the fucking ocean.
Oh my god.
There you go.
Jesus is a little wide.
Where is it?
Turn around.
Oh my god.
There it is.
Yeah.
Okay.
I...
Jesus please.
Oh mighty.
Oh my god.
We...
Of course we chose the thinnest piece of wood too.
I need...
I need to blow my nose.
I need more tissue.
I'll be right back.
I...
Okay.
I need water too.
Wow, she left so fast.
Oh.
She's gone.
This...
Okay, I'm gonna find a better walkthrough.
Because this...
This one...
Screenrant.com.
You suck.
They only...
Well, you know, I...
They wanted you to do the mirrors in a certain order.
And Doki definitely did not.
She just kind of went off on her own.
I had no time to stop her.
So...
Um...
Oh, there are pills in the bathroom.
And...
I wonder if she already grabbed those though.
Like, are they pills that...
Regenerate or...
Yeah, I'm back.
I'm back.
And like, our biggest issue is the fact that we don't have any pills.
So, I don't know what to do.
I'm...
Um...
Yeah?
It says...
Uh...
If we go back upstairs, we might be able to find some in the bathroom and in the parents' room.
They regenerated for us?
I don't know.
This is just what the...
NeoSeeker.com Visage 2020 Dolores chapter walkthrough says.
Oh, hey, a shotgun.
Whoa!
Oh my god, I can shoot the ghost.
Gear me up.
Wait, we got him.
This is a miracle.
It's Resident Evil.
Why is there doom music all of a sudden?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Is this Resident Evil?
Oh.
No way.
We did all of that for what?
What is this?
What?
Hello?
I swear to God, if I turn around and I see her, I swear to God.
If I turn around and she is behind me, I swear to fucking God.
Okay, no.
Okay.
What?
Then what do we do?
What do we do?
Your fucking screen rent.com took us to an Easter egg instead of progressing that day.
This was not the screen read guide.
Your fucking screen read guide took us to a goddamn easter egg.
Instead of getting me out.
Instead of finding me a fucking crowbar.
All I needed was a crowbar.
The crowbar.
Well, you went all out of order.
It's not my fault.
What do you mean I went out of order?
I followed your guy.
I got nothing.
We don't have the... How do we get the... I have to go back.
I have to go back.
Wait, the crowbar is... Oh my gosh.
Let's see.
All of these...
All of these guides have a very specific order.
They want you to do things.
Oh my guide.
I have to go back.
Ship me my way back from that mirror.
So I can find the first crank.
Maybe.
Okay.
Let's see.
There's a crowbar.
There's a... Oh.
Where's the crowbar?
Where...
It's really just not that easy to tell you where it is.
What do you...
Okay.
Do you want to hear what we have to go through?
To get the crowbar, we gotta get the butcher's knife.
To get the butcher's knife, we gotta go to the tea box key.
To get the T-box key, or then we gotta get the infusion pack, and then we gotta get the T-small key, and then we gotta get the cloud toy, then we gotta get the specialty, and then we gotta get the baby monitor, and then we gotta get the photograph hand.
Do 80% of that fucking chapter!
What do you mean?
What do you mean by baby monitor?
What do you mean by... Oh my god!
What?
Where am I?
Where even are we?
I don't know where we are.
Yeah, me neither.
I feel like we've done nothing to... I feel like we're at, like, the 10% of this chapter.
We've done, like, nothing to actually progress.
I... I don't...
Yeah.
Wait, it says, at the top of the stairs... Wait, you have to go back to where we were.
Sorry.
Oh, wait.
No, never mind.
Sorry.
We got to get the crank.
Where is the crank?
Oh, fuck!
That's what I was trying to say!
Where the fuck is the crank?
The crank is... Oh, remember where the circle mirrors were?
We got to go back there.
We have to go... Oh, my God.
How do we get out of the basement?
We're stuck down here!
Oh, my God.
We're soft-locked.
There is no way.
I... Are we soft-locked?
Are we actually soft-locked?
Well, you just started doing things on your own and I was trying to help you with...
No, but there's probably a mirror that we can go through.
There's a bathroom hole.
Where was the bathroom?
There's apparently a bathroom hole.
Oh, yeah.
In the bathroom.
Remember?
There was a bathroom.
Oh, my...
Alright, so unpause and go to the left.
Okay.
Nope.
Turn around.
Turn... Yeah, that way.
Okay.
And it's... To the right here?
Yeah, that door that's... Uh-oh.
Oh!
Just kill me.
End me.
Just...
Just take me out, cranny.
Just take me out of this world.
Wait, but we were so close to getting out of there.
Oh, my God.
We were not close at all.
And sweet, merciful grandma, please get me out of here.
I can't...
La la la la la la... La la la la la...
La la la la la... Where does it take me?
Oh, my God.
There's... I like how the sledgehammer is right there.
Okay.
Do I have... Still have my... Now, right to the right.
To the right.
Okay.
I need to get this fucking hammer out of my hand.
Drop... Alright.
Nice.
Alright.
See right there?
The door that's open?
Yeah.
That's the bathroom.
Oh, my fucking hole.
Yeah.
See, you just never looked inside here.
Oh, my God.
I don't...
You just kind of... You just did a little peek and then you just never...
You know... Oh, did you just die?
Wow.
That'd be nice.
God, thank God.
But we know how to get back to the basement.
Now we know how to get back upstairs, so...
Oh.
Oh, my God.
We're back here.
Okay.
Our... Our favorite area.
Huh?
Oh.
She's coming after you?
She's behind me and she... She's behind me and she...
Oh, my God.
How... Why is she chasing us?
Like, this must be timed or something, because...
Wait, you're going to a dead end.
I know, but she was chasing me.
Oh, yeah, you're fine.
Yeah, but why would you go to a dead... I guess you could have looped her in there.
Yeah.
Okay, where would that... I forgot.
Okay.
Where was that mirror?
Where the fuck was that mirror?
Upstairs.
Okay.
I'm pretty sure it was upstairs.
By the...
The bedroom on the other side.
Yeah, over here.
Right?
There it is.
Oh.
Oh!
You gotta break it.
You gotta go get the sunshine.
I'm... I hope she kills me.
I...
Oh, my God.
Oh, go answer the door this time.
It might kill you.
Which door?
The front door!
Right there!
The one on your left.
I can't...
Pizza.
Oh, she's right there.
Look at her.
Oh, she's gone.
It's so sad.
Oh, she turned off all the lights.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
You remember how to get downstairs, right?
To the basement?
Oh, my God!
Weeeee!
Oh, my God.
What?
Why didn't we save this chapter for last?
Why?
You chose this.
Don't include me.
I don't know anything about this game.
Why?
Where's the hole?
No, no, no.
Get the sledgehammer.
Get the sledgehammer!
The storage in this game... or the item... inventory management in this game is whack.
This... this... it's actually whack.
Oh yeah, and you still have one more chapter.
If you... Oh, you should do like the... you know how you can have your eyes...
have like the dark circles underneath them?
That would be a perfect time for that.
You're enjoying this.
If I could take this hammer...
It's what?
To my head?
Alright, upstairs.
Upstairs.
If only I could just take this hammer and end it all.
Why is it so dark?
Right there.
And smash.
Smashy, smashy.
How is it decreasing fast?
There's light!
Oh, is this the right one?
Hold on.
I swear to god.
It is.
Uh, there might be someone chasing after you.
I am hammering this as fast as I can!
Like, I don't...
Like, I...
Clearly...
Please, please don't...
Oh, that was close.
Oh, there she is!
Hello!
She seems so nice up there!
I don't understand!
I don't think she died!
What is grandpa-ass cough ever?
I could be the grandpa.
Okay.
Okay, what's this?
So, in this room...
There are bodies hanging.
Yeah?
Pick up and read the poem.
Look, there's another lighter!
What does it say?
Whirling in an everlasting dream.
You can read the rest.
Oh, oh.
A two-sided moon with clouded vision lies down innocently by its guilty shadow.
Okay, so now we have to inspect the bodies.
You two don't look.
I've never actually been flagged for like... Oh, is that a person standing there or...
That's just another body.
It's just shrouded in shadow.
Wait, there's a lot of candles.
Yeah.
Oh wait, there's so many candles.
This inventory is so ass.
I'm sorry.
Why can't I carry more?
I know, I don't get it.
But don't leave just yet.
You got to do the puzzle.
There's a puzzle here?
Yes, that's what the poem is for.
Oh.
There will be some bodies with drawings of eye, moon, and shadow on them.
Where?
I could tell you, but I think you should find them.
Oh, that one's for...
Why is it curved like that?
There's nothing...
Oh, there it is.
That's a butterfly.
That is not an eye, a moon, or a shadow.
Or wait, what is it?
Yeah, eye, moon, shadow.
What does a shadow look like?
Nothing else.
It's just that one body.
No, there's gotta be.
I'm looking and I found one body.
Yep, just one.
Go to the other side of the room.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, eye!
Okay.
Did you interact with it?
Oh, there it is.
A moon!
Alright, we found it all.
Wait, did you get the shadow?
My sledgehammer was stored.
Oh, man.
That's a butterfly.
That's it.
Is it shadow of a butterfly?
Oh, there it is.
Oh!
Alright, remember where it is.
Two are back here.
Wait, is that it?
Nothing at all.
What's the point?
That has to be the shadow.
What?
Ah.
This?
Okay, try interacting with it.
That's all I did.
I just...
Oh, wait, hold on.
Proceed up the stairs.
By the light, you will find the crank.
Or is it this?
Wait, this doesn't seem to depict anything at all.
A slider.
Maybe it's the skull.
I think it will say shadow, no?
Hold on.
Uh...
You're going so fast.
I could tell you where they are, but you're going so fast!
Oh, yeah.
I found them.
Okay.
You got it!
Alright.
Okay, now I guess we can leave.
What was the point of finding?
The greatest horror of them all.
Puzzles.
Oh.
But I have no crank.
It's here.
The crank is here.
Yay!
Why are you so allergic to the light?
Wait.
Okay.
Okay, so the chair...
Use the crank to open the skylights above the bodies.
It was these.
With the...
The ones with the drawings.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's my candy.
I'll trust.
I'll trust you to remember.
Wait, I said you remembered.
I told you to remember it.
It was this one, right?
Well, you said it was here.
I mean, you opened it.
I don't know.
You can go back downstairs and see which one is lit up.
I can...
I know what to do.
You do?
What are you gonna do?
I'm gonna crank it, soldier boy.
Up in that...
Whoa!
Watch her, crank it.
Watch her.
Whoa!
Superman at...
Yeah.
Ayoo!
Okay, what was the other one?
The moon.
It was right here.
You remember?
I don't know.
Oh, I remembered.
Wow.
You actually did remember.
I did it.
I think you go back downstairs now.
And it opens up that.
Did you see me do it?
Did you see that?
I'm proud of you.
How proud of you are you?
Let's try that again.
I'm not okay right now.
I hate this chapter so much.
But we got the crank!
I hate this chapter.
We've made progress!
I don't...
I don't want to fucking...
Now we can go back to the basement.
And use the crank.
Where are we?
I don't know anymore.
Oh, we're in the basement!
Wait, why are you pausing?
I need a moment.
What's happening?
Oh.
Why?
Nothing happened!
I need a moment.
What happened?
When the candy comes over, it takes a life.
I need a moment right now.
No, no!
All we have to do is go to the left and that's where the crank was!
Oh my god!
Nothing happened!
Grandma's not even scary!
Uh...
Ay-yi-yi-yi!
I'm a little butterfly!
It's so good to put you in a hole!
I can't!
Alright!
Let's go!
Woohoo!
Okay.
So go to the left.
And that mirror right there.
That's not...
Oh, just run for it.
Run for it.
Go!
No, no!
Why did you not go to the mirror?
Oh, is this...
Oh, you're right.
Yeah!
Yeah, you wanna know why I didn't go to that mirror?
Yeah, that's okay, right?
I...
Oh.
I'm the backseater.
I'm the backseater!
To be fair, I'm not the one playing the game, so I don't remember.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Go back in there.
Yeah, I'm the one guy.
I really am.
You're the one guy.
I was testing Doki's.
Oh, why are you...
Why are you...
Why are you going to that mirror, Doki?
I hate you!
Yeah, yeah.
I'm the one...
One of us.
The longer we play, the more she regresses into the one guy.
I'm becoming the one guy.
I should probably pay attention more to this.
Oh, it's the other one that has the crowbar.
I remember.
Where is this guy?
Oh my god, he is risen!
Oh my god, on the third day.
Do you think he has the crowbar in him?
It's gonna defile Christ to see if there is.
Gonna stick my hand into his chest.
Wow.
Happy Easter, everybody.
Oh, it's a...
Oh, it's a butcher knife!
I was like, what the fuck you meant by butcher knife?
See, I told you I wasn't crazy.
Oh my god.
Oh look, there's an easter egg.
Yeah, there's the easter egg.
Get an easter egg!
Oh my god, alright.
Now where do I have to go with that butcher knife?
I'm holding on.
Where do I have to go?
Where do we have to go?
Okay.
Yes.
We have to go to...
Okay, get the sledgehammer and we gotta go to the...
second...
Wait, hold on.
What?
Hold on.
The second what?
Yes, we gotta go to the second floor office.
Oh!
Daddy's office?
Yeah, daddy's office.
Okay, okay.
Time to daddy's office.
Alright, time to go to papa's office.
Papa!
How would anyone solve this?
I don't.
I don't know.
Especially with like, when it went to grandma.
Yeah, and limited resources.
And limited resources.
Oh my god.
Second floor office.
Okay.
The knife, we needed it for this, for this, for the office.
But, we'll get something that you might remember that we needed too.
So, we'll be able to solve another puzzle.
Well, we'll speed run these.
Because we kind of already did some of these.
So like, we could just speed run through some of them.
Where'd you go?
Doki?
Don't give me a sec.
I feel mentally prepared myself.
Because I know Granny's gonna chase me when I have this stupid fucking hammer on me.
Oh, yeah.
Um.
Give me a sec.
I'm just disassociating for five seconds before I'm back into this mortal plane of existence.
I uh By Elie.
Ey!
A little samurai.
No, that's where you went in, remember?
Yes, and that's how you get out.
That's where you...
Sorry, I'm the worst today.
I'm the worst today.
What do you mean?
Do you know how to go in to go out?
I'm really testing you.
I just...
Guys, don't blame me, okay?
I'm on new meds, okay?
It makes my brain foggy!
All I can remember are the lyrics to Butterfly!
Oh my god, she's coming back.
It's fine, you're going through a hole.
Oh my god.
This is why I can't find any meds, she took them all.
Me?
She took them all.
No, you definitely took them all.
I'm on.
Okie dokie.
I-I-I-I-I-I.
I-I-I-I-I.
Ay-I-I-I-I-I-I-I.
Ay-I-I-I-I-I.
Ay-I-I-I-I-I-I-i...
Alright.
Second floor.
Oh my god, there it is.
She can't see you if you can't see her.
Papa!
Oh, there's the bag.
Yeah, see, remember I said you'll find something that you will need.
And then I'll stick it in him.
Yeah, stick in the knife.
It's like, you know, like the...
Pop a pirate!
Let's see if her head comes off!
He's gonna spring to life!
Yay!
Pop that pirate!
Pop a pirate!
It's like monkeys in a barrel, too.
Oh, there's the key!
I love you!
Oh, there it is!
What a great way to say it!
Okay.
Wait a second.
Alright, I found a small key.
I'm waiting.
I don't need pills.
I'm reading the instructions.
Yeah.
I'm gonna throw this away.
So I hope that I don't need it anymore.
Okay.
So the part after this was what we did where we followed the guy and he was like, led us to the room with the peepholes.
What?
So, remember the...
So, we already did that part.
Yeah.
Remember we followed the guy and he led us like through the garage and everything and all around.
So, then...
We go to...
We gotta give the...
Remember the hospital?
Area?
Where is that?
Remember when she was in the little hospital area?
She was like a...
She was like...
Like a shadow?
Yeah.
I don't remember where that was.
Hold on though.
Before we do that...
Oh wait.
No, never mind.
Hold on.
What the fuck is the shadow room?
I'm trying to read!
Oh, we gotta go to...
The peephole room.
No, we gotta go to the...
To the...
Remember when she was shadowed?
Remember?
In the shadow realm?
Peephole.
Stop following the guide!
We need to go to the shadow...
I'm trying...
It's not telling me where the shadow room is!
It's stuck as a shadow grandma!
Stop the peephole!
Um...
It's stuck as a shadow room!
What thing?
Where was it?
I don't remember!
I'm thinking!
Uh...
Peephole!
It really isn't...
Okay.
Hold on.
There will be...
Three paintings.
Okay, it says...
Oh my god!
We know that's the room!
You read that mine!
I'm giving this to you!
You can read it!
Because it's not telling me where to go!
Yeah!
You're giving it to me!
I'm controlling the game!
You're the navigator!
You know like when you're driving a car up the map!
The TV room!
Where the fuck is...
Oh my god!
On the first floor!
I can't read if you're yelling at me!
I feel like we're like on a road trip right now!
Trying to navigate to fucking the Niagara Falls or some fucking...
We're driving to the Niagara Falls right now!
And we're trying to bring out like...
We should pull over and ask for directions and chat is our direction!
Like we're pulling over on the side of the road to ask chat where to go!
We could go back to the peephole!
Okay!
Go to the...
Go to the TV room on the first floor!
Okay!
This is like keep talking and nobody explodes!
But when... go!
Okay!
Alright!
Play the game!
I told you where to go!
Okay!
Give me a sec!
Let me...
Grab something sweet!
I just thought the guide would give me a pick!
A picture would have turned it!
Okay!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Peephole!
Are we there yet?
That room, that room, that room!
Straight ahead, straight ahead, straight ahead...
Nope!
Straight ahead!
Okay, remember where the mirror is?
Okay, there it is!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a peepo.
Peepo!
Actually, I really just want her to say peepo.
Alright, we're gonna give Granny her baggie back.
Her little grab bag.
Granny!
Granny, we got it for you.
We got the insulin bag.
Is it insulin?
Infusion.
Oh my god.
She has diabetes.
She reduced to atoms.
A sun toy.
Peepo.
That's the peepo.
Oh!
Remember that one baby thing was missing the little toys.
Yeah.
Alright, now we're going to the wardrobe in the basement.
There's some wardrobe in the basement.
Mirror 5.
Where's the... Someone said I didn't get the cloud toy.
Where's the cloud toy?
Wait, what's the cloud toy?
Is it that what... Is it in the... Where we... Oh my god.
Grandma!
Just go into... Yeah, Papa's room.
Wait, can she get us in here?
No, apparently she can't go into mirrors.
Haha, stupid Dolores.
Stupid Dolores.
Where is she?
I think she's gone.
They told me like, I forgot something in this room.
But clearly I... Oh my god, they lied.
Uh, hold on.
They fucking lied.
Uh, hold on, I'm looking.
Cloud...
Toy...
Oh!
Interact with the box on the...
Desk.
To pick up an audio cassette and a cloud mobile toy.
Wait, where are we going?
What is this?
I don't know.
Where is this?
How did you... How did you find this?
What is this?
I don't even know anymore.
Wait, where are we?
I don't know.
Where am I?
What is this?
What happened?
I looked away for two seconds.
There we go.
There's the cloud.
What's in there?
Are those a bunch of IV bags?
So we could've just grabbed one of these?
Yeah, we could've just grabbed one of these.
It's jammed.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That's it?
Yep, that's it.
Oh!
Oh wait, no, he's friendly.
I don't think so.
I just don't know.
I just saw you wanted to say hi.
I don't know.
I just...
What did I do?
I...
The...
The latest auto save, I guess.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Um, it says, leave the room to find George standing.
From here, re-enter the room and slowly shut the door when he starts to walk towards you.
It's just be like, nope.
Yeah, pretty much.
Just literally deny him any access.
Just close the door.
And he just gave you a British hello.
I have to
do...
I didn't realize I had to do this all over again.
Why didn't I auto-save when you grabbed the cloud?
I know, that's what I was thinking!
What the hell?
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Where was that again?
Oh yeah, we were running away from...
It's on the second floor.
Yeah.
We were running away from Grandma.
She's being like...
Booga, booga, booga, booga, I need my meds.
She's about to show up, right?
Grandma?
No?
Maybe not.
Okay, so...
We're gonna let this guy walk towards us.
But we're gonna...
I didn't even notice this was a door.
I only noticed because it was like slanted over there.
And then like people in my chat...
Like, you know, when I pulled over for directions in the car...
They were like, you should go back to the room.
And I was like, okay.
Oh, I...
You know, I...
It was so dark I couldn't see.
Why didn't you do anything, huh?
It was just so dark I couldn't see.
Okay, quick save now.
I don't think it lets me.
Yeah.
This is so messed up.
I have to...
Okay, now shut the door when he comes at you.
Oh, shut the door!
Shut the door!
Get me!
I think we're good.
Are we though?
Oh god.
I don't know, I hope so!
What if he's right there?
He's around the corner!
Cut.
Okay, now that's...
We gotta go to the basement.
You remember how to get to the basement?
No.
Well, who's speaking gibberish?
It's the grandma.
Yeah, down here.
It's always here.
She's always there watching me.
What's the wardrobe in the basement?
What the fuck?
That's where Jesus was.
That's the Jesus level.
I swear to god.
You bring me back to the fucking Easter egg.
I swear to fucking god.
No, we gotta do...
We gotta give Dolores her tea.
What?
Yeah, we haven't found this one yet.
No, that was the closet, no?
I don't know what the...
Can you quicksave here?
Oh my god.
The one near the mannequin.
The one near the mannequin, Doki.
Do I have...
If I unlocked it, though?
I don't know.
So go to the mannequin.
Oh, oh!
I saved, wow.
Wow.
No.
Oh, mannequin.
Yeah.
Is it the one up there?
Or no?
Did we get one over here?
Oh, that says the wardrobe.
Right there.
Maybe it's inside the wardrobe.
I need a mirror.
I need...
I know there's a hammer.
I need to grab the hammer.
I need to grab the fucking hammer.
Uh...
It says next to the wardrobe.
It's right there.
I saw it.
Oh, you did?
You saw it?
It's right here.
Oh!
Smash!
Hello, Granny.
What took you so long, George?
Tea.
Okay.
Where is tea?
Oh my god.
Hey, look.
There's another...
Oh my god.
What's she talking about?
Oh, there's a cassette tape.
I'm beginning to make you love your work more than me.
She's just yapping.
Use the sledgehammer.
I want to be able to see what the...
Oh my god.
And I can't light it up.
This is all your fault.
My fault!
Would you be a doll?
You've actually some of my specialties.
You know where you are.
I can't get here.
She won't let me get here.
You...
Where's the tea box?
Okay, so the tea...
Hold on!
You heard her.
She said she needs her tea.
It's up in the attic.
Okay.
Save soon, Dwyane.
The door to...
Or the hole is right there.
Into the hole I go.
Do I need my sledgehammer?
I don't remember for it.
I'm dropping this.
If I don't need this, I'm gonna drop this hammer right about now.
It's...
I think you'll be okay, actually.
Why is...
Oh, wait.
Yeah, you might be okay.
Because you already broke the mirror, you know?
I don't remember.
I...
Just keep it.
Just hold on to it.
It's fine.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Alright, time to go upstairs, baby.
Honk!
Who's speaking gibberish?
I don't care anymore.
You remember where the...
Attic is?
Uh, do you remember how to turn on the light?
No.
I think you can drop the sledgehammer.
I'll be honest.
Is it here or is it here?
Uh, it's behind...
Uh, yeah.
Up there.
Right there.
Then you use that thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Alright!
Okay.
Alright.
This chapter is less scary and more like...
I just want to put granny in a home.
Yeah, pretty much.
What the hell is that?
That pisses me off.
That's what I was thinking, too.
There it is.
Sun and tea.
Okay.
Alright, we got some special tea.
Oh, wait.
Hold on, hold on.
Hold on.
What?
Uh...
Bring the tea.
Okay, yeah.
You can bring it back to her.
Okay.
I'll pause my game.
I need to blow my nose.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
But what makes...
We're on mirror?
What makes the tea so...
There was no way we could do this without the guide.
I...
I feel like...
No.
There was no way.
I...
I'm so fucking done with this.
No.
I'm glad I looked it up.
Even when we stopped our car to ask chat for directions, it was...
I don't think even, like, anybody else would be able to describe each step that you have to do.
Like, it's insane.
There's so...
I don't know.
There's so much to this.
There's no direction.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
We go to Dolores, right?
Yep.
Where was her?
Back to Dolores.
In the basement.
Okay.
The mannequin room.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
First off, I want to go here.
Oh, grab that.
Can you...
Wait, you can't grab it.
Okay, never mind.
I can't, but I can put this away.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
We just need three...
What?
Okay.
Now...
Now I listen to my...
There's so...
The honking...
Oh, my God.
Let me just listen to this, Lord.
I listened to this already.
I lost track of all the tapes I have.
I don't think so.
We only listened to one.
I don't remember which one we listened to.
They all look the same to me.
I'm going to be late for tea.
Oh, this tells us where the tea was.
Oh, we should have been listening to this this entire time.
This literally tells us how to progress the game.
This was our guide.
They don't really explain that that's why you have to...
You have to keep coming here to figure out how to progress.
I guess so.
She sometimes forgets where she is or even the fact that... This was our guide.
They literally recorded in a guide for us.
The gibberish.
Oh, that's her.
Come on, engage!
Oh, she has dementia.
That's rough, buddy.
That's really rough.
Look, this is your favorite people room.
People!
Uh-oh.
Not today, grandma.
Not today.
Okay, don't she suck?
I don't think she's gonna chase you.
She's not there.
Oh,
why is she like this?
Like, why is she like this?
It might just be...
It might just be a...
A thing.
Like a...
A little...
Spook...
A spooky moment.
Oh my god.
Why is she like this though?
I don't think she will.
That's not fair.
Look through the people.
Not gonna look through you stupid people!
And we can finish that mission!
We don't need them!
Wait, she opened the door herself.
Wait, that's legal.
I don't need you.
Okay, we need...
We need to go again.
We need to go to...
The basement.
The basement, okay.
So you gotta go down the stairs.
Fucking hell.
Oh see, I told you.
It was just a...
It was just a thing.
Hunk.
At least there's always one constant in this.
And it's the fact that the car alarm is still going.
Alright.
Back to the staircase.
The wheeling staircase.
That's not what this is.
Weeeeee...
I love you!
I don't remember how to get there.
Mannequin, mannequin.
Yes, but how do we get there?
Turn...
Well, yeah, you can go there.
And then to the left.
There it is.
Down the stairs, yep.
I can be useful sometimes.
Oh my god, finally the one guy that said the right thing.
Okay.
Wait, she's not even here.
She's not even here, this ungrateful bitch.
I know.
Contains hot water.
Do you need both hands to grab the tea?
We have one?
Oh my god!
What do we have point setting?
I've been the light!
I've been a cutscene!
I can't just leave the fucking cutscene!
Oh my god.
That's what we tried to do to her and she got really upset about it.
You know what?
Maybe deserved on our part.
I told you to put it home!
Oh my god!
Where are we?
We're now in Half-Life.
Oh,
we're in the people room.
Where are we?
Wait, how did the ghost hit me?
Ghost can't...
Wait, what?
What?
Are we in the oven?
We're in the oven!
How did she put us in here?
Yeah.
How did you lock the oven?
How did the ghost lock me in an oven?
Uh-oh.
Yeah, how big is this oven?
Am I...
Okay, I was gonna say...
I was like...
Is this like Resident Evil where I'm supposed to look around?
We're fine.
How the fuck did I fit in there?
I thought I was a grown-ass man!
World's smallest man.
Yeah, I'm five foot eight.
Alright, and we got the little star.
That was cute.
That was a cute star.
Almost being...
Okay!
...forget that there's murderers out here.
Nice!
Now we can...
Get out of here.
And we can go to that one...
That had the...
Are you serious?
I have the whole...
Oh my god.
Yeah, you need both hands for it too.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you fucking...
Okay.
Yeah, you know where to go.
It's been 20 years.
Where is the window?
Okay, the one...
I'm almost positive.
It's the one that I thought...
Remember how I was like, Why are you running past it?
I'm almost positive it's that one.
Oh no!
Yeah.
Wait.
No.
It's the one...
No, yeah.
Let me pause the game.
It's that one!
And then the one...
The one by the stairs is the playground.
This is the...
This is the one.
Which one?
I have it.
You said I ran past...
I ran past 20 mirrors.
Which mirror?
Okay.
Remember...
She was chasing you.
And I was like, We gotta get to the place with the crank.
And I was like, Why are you running past it?
That's the wardrobe.
It's not...
No, no, no, no.
We are in the wardrobe.
We are...
This is the wardrobe mirror.
What you need to know is...
go back to the basement TV room.
Remember where the electrical...
Key...
Door is...
It's right next to that.
No!
That door is locked.
What?
No!
Yes!
What?
Yes, that door is locked!
The electric door.
The electrical room door.
The mirror next to... Leave this room.
You know how to get back to the TV.
Yes.
Okay, get back to the TV.
But the basement TV, not the upstairs TV.
Yes.
Okay.
Alright.
It's here.
Yeah, yeah.
Go all the way down to the end and then to the right.
That one right there.
That door is locked.
Was that not locked?
Was it not this one?
I told you.
I know.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I have no idea then.
I don't know where it is.
A near basement bathroom.
Where's that?
Well, I know where the bathroom is.
Base...
There's a...
Oh!
I know where it is.
Okay.
Go back to the one by the wardrobe.
I told you!
The locked one!
What do you mean?
I thought you meant the outside door was locked.
I'm so locked.
Is it the one right here?
Oh, turn around.
Turn around.
Right there.
Try that one.
I was next to this one too!
I was next to this one!
I forgot this one existed!
Who gave you the fucking GPS?
Okay, to be fair, all it says is basement hallway.
How the hell am I supposed to know what that means?
It's also been 20 years for me!
Your entire job was to navigate!
How do you screw it up?
It just says basement hallway!
Oh my god!
In front of your face!
It says basement hallway and that's it!
It's a damn compass.
And now we go to the park.
I trust you know where that is.
Why do you trust me?
I have not been remembering where anything is!
What do you mean?
Okay, remember!
No, I don't remember!
Let me speak!
No!
I actually know where this one is!
Okay.
Um...
So, it's...
It's...
You go through the little...
In the basement.
You go through the windy hallway.
Yes.
And that leads you upstairs.
That's like to the kitchen.
What?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you go through...
Okay, keep...
Go straight.
Or you could go downstairs.
Or...
I don't actually know how to get there.
Here?
Through here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Remember?
No!
And then you go...
Straight!
This way!
Oh my god, okay.
This one!
I'm going crazier and crazier right now.
I...
My...
My brain...
So now...
The compass will let you go through Silent Hill.
Okay...
Where are you going?
Go to Silent Hill.
I'm looking at the compass!
I'm just telling you to go outside the walls!
I'm just...
I'm just trying to follow the goddamn compass!
Yeah, go that way.
I guess.
I don't know.
Go somewhere.
Alright, welcome to Silent Hill.
The...
Spring!
Alright.
Uh, we're leaving, we're leaving the place.
We're finally out of here.
Oh my god.
Freedom!
Why are you hugging the wall like something's gonna...
Nothing can come up to my right side.
Alright, now there's gonna be an open grave.
Oh wait, it closed the door on me.
It closed on you.
Yeah.
Doctor Who.
Doctor Who?
Where is it?
There's gonna be the open grave somewhere around here.
You just gotta go find it.
Everything is a grave.
Open.
Open grave.
They're all graves.
I don't think there's... I haven't seen a single grave actually.
Maybe it's back here.
Maybe.
Oh!
Oh wait, what's that down there?
Look at the mausoleum.
No, no, no.
On the ground.
Oh hey!
What is that?
It's a collectible.
Nevermind.
Yeah, I don't think that mattered.
That didn't matter.
Am I supposed to look at my compass?
It might lead you.
Oh, I can't go past this area.
I mean, there's graves here.
That's disrespectful.
You're like...
Go around here.
Just keep searching.
We're safe in here.
This is easy town.
Or Britain.
I don't know.
London.
I mean, the husband did shank me.
So I don't think...
It's...
We're in London.
I think we're in London right now.
It was not...
I see London.
I see France.
I see...
Minky's...
Underpants.
Yeah, on my new GamerSupps merch.
Use code COKEYBIRD on Min's new GamerSupp drop.
Oh.
Is that the grave?
Oh, there it is.
It's a crib.
There it is.
Oh, that's kind of sad.
Oh my god.
Is the baby dead?
I think everybody's dead.
No?
Oh.
No, the baby's alive!
He's alive!
You're alive!
We just buried you alive!
That's alright, little baby.
Oh my gosh.
This reminds me.
There was a lady who parked really bad.
She kept parking really bad.
Like, taking up multiple parking spots.
And so, I wanted so badly to leave little rocks all over her windshield.
I thought you were like, you wanted to bury her alive or something.
Cut to, you know?
Alright.
Oh, there's another easter egg in here.
We are not doing this fucking...
Okay, so a compass would lead me home, right?
Hold on.
Uh, after the cutscene, open the box.
Wait, did you- Oh, you got the toy.
Yeah, I did.
And then, return to the statue and take a right.
Oh.
Oh, for an easter egg.
Nevermind.
Go back to the way you came.
Alright, is it a fun easter egg?
It doesn't tell me what it is.
It just says for an easter egg.
Alright, let's see.
Wait.
Let's see what there is.
There's a statue.
Before reaching the gate, take the small path to the right.
To a dead end.
It's this one.
Or...
This one?
Easter egg.
Is this a flower?
It doesn't- It literally doesn't tell me what it is.
It's this.
This is a dead end.
Okay.
And follow it.
Oh, people are saying it's the flower.
That's not an easter egg though.
That's just a flower.
That's like a collectible.
Yeah.
Oh, there's a dead end here.
JK.
Okay.
Oh, someone said it was a flower.
Oh, okay.
Nevermind.
Okay, I'm lost now.
Where am I?
No, there's an- Oh, no!
This is the easter egg.
Oh.
Press- Press F to pay-
That it?
What's that sound from?
Same, bro.
I don't- Where's that- That guy was letting out all his frustrations from this game.
Okay, we found the real easter egg.
We found the real easter egg, guys.
See?
I did it one guy.
You, everyone else, he chatted.
We would've missed out on that Kino moment, everybody.
It was so important.
Me when I'm- It was so important.
Me when I'm playing massage.
Oh, my God.
Paid respect, guys.
That was so silly.
Oh, my God.
So silly.
Okay.
We can leave now.
All right.
Out we go.
To freedom.
Wait.
Look to the right.
Is there- No.
Oh.
It says something in the mausoleum, so I think actually you gotta go back up to that mausoleum.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Oh, hold on.
Turn right.
There.
This way.
I think we go down this way.
The guide is not very clear.
Screen ray, I have- I have a lot of issues.
I- I- Read you what it says to me.
Okay.
Um.
Interact with the grave to start a cutscene.
After the cutscene, open the box.
Grab the toy.
Return the same way down the walkway back to the statue.
Take a right for an Easter egg just before reaching the gate.
Is it- Which gate is it talking about?
It's this one.
Take the small path.
Then go back the same way to reach the gate.
Exit through the gate to find the door to the mausoleum on the right and open it.
So go back the mausoleum.
Oh my God, we should- Oh my God, it was the mausoleum this entire time.
It's fine.
It's not even that far away.
It's the- the gate, Doki.
It's the gate.
The gate.
How could you not notice the fucking gate?
It's the gate!
It's right here!
There's like only five gates in this area!
How am I supposed to know which gate was the gate?
Oh my God, there's the gate.
The gate?
The gate.
Okay, now we're gonna go to where the progress room is.
But you need the hammer for it.
Oh, fuck, okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
Down I go.
Wee!
If you put your hands up in the air, it feels even faster!
Oh my god, how far is this area?
Wee!
That could have been a cutscene.
Like a driving cutscene!
You could have made this a cutscene for me!
Oh, but you're in the basement, so you can just grab the sledgehammer and go.
Okay.
You know, I don't think you need the compass anymore, but don't trust...
I'm not gonna trust you.
Yeah.
Grab that bad boy, and then we'll go through the toilet hole.
Toilet hole we go.
Yeah.
The boy's hole.
The troll.
Go, troll.
It be...
Oh my god, why does this take like 50 seconds?
You jump through this hole like 30 times.
You do not have to be like, is this safe?
Like...
I know!
Every time!
I would save also if you can.
Yeah, I'll have to get out of this door to be able to save.
Yeah.
Okie dokie.
Oh, there's a baby crying.
Baby, stop crying.
And a car honking.
Baby, stop crying!
Alright, you remember how to get to the progress room.
Yes.
No.
Uh.
Right here.
Yeah.
Oh.
What was that?
Smashy, smashy.
Oh my god, the fuck?
Woah!
Say goodbye to baby.
It's like taking candy from a baby.
The baby is holding a spear.
Oh my god.
The orb.
The baby orb.
Mine.
Ok, hold on.
Uh.
Yep.
Ok, you're gonna take...
Oh.
Ok, what do I do?
Uh.
You're gonna take the spear to the garage.
What do I do in the garage with the spear?
Oh, but there's gonna be a sequence where Dolores is...
Is trying to catch you.
Oh my god.
So, um, basically...
Yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
Basically, um...
There's gonna be a work bench on...
In the garage to break open the spear.
How am I going crazy?
Because we're in the womb!
It has light!
The womb makes me crazy!
Ok.
Ok, but...
Beep.
Wait, wasn't that the...
You could've gone to the garage from there, I guess.
But, it's fine.
Yeah.
I just wanna take a leisure walk when Dolores tries to kill me.
I guess maybe she's not coming there.
I don't know.
Do this?
Ok, that thing right there.
I'm pretty sure.
Do this?
I think we skipped the cutscene.
That's nice.
I'm going crazy while I'm doing this?
How?
I'm in the alarm!
Because of the alarm!
The alarm!
What's right?
It should be reassuring me!
Ok, let's read the note.
I didn't read it.
Oh.
Uh.
There it is.
Oh.
Uh.
Um.
Oh.
There it goes.
How are we supposed to read it?
Ok, there we go.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, it's the clock!
Remember the clocks?
No, did you remember the clock?
One was 1230, one was...
What does all of this mean?
Well, luckily we have a guide that will help us.
Alright, so now...
First floor hallway where the Felix the Cat clock was near the bookshelves.
What?
Yeah, yeah.
Mirror number nine is in the first floor hallway near some bookshelves.
Break the mirror and enter...
Remember that's where the...
That's where the...
The clocks.
The clocks are.
Ok.
Yeah.
I need to pee.
Ok.
Yeah.
Um...
Guys, we're on mirror nine out of...
Eleven.
We're definitely gonna finish this today.
Thank goodness for...
For the, uh...
Walkthrough, huh?
Hi, Mint.
Hi!
Mmm...
I'm doing my best as a...
As a little guide, you know?
Yeah.
How does one play this without a guide?
I don't know.
This one has a lot of text underneath it though.
So I'm gonna read it right now to you guys.
We're gonna all read it together.
Ok.
Mirror number nine is on the first floor hallway near some bookshelves.
Break the mirror and enter the large square hallway.
That's the one with the clocks.
Use the note from mirror eight to set the clocks on the left wall.
Ok.
And then I have what they should be set to.
So I could cheat, but I'm gonna let Doki read it.
Then turn left to follow the hall.
Arrange the decorative plates.
Did we see plates?
In this area based on the note as well.
The plate with the man on it should be turned three times until the head faces left.
While the woman's plate should be turned once so the head faces to the right.
Lastly, the center plate with the mother and the baby should stay upright.
Read it in Kermit voice.
Ahem.
Now turn left to continue following the hall.
Across from the hanging clothes, use the note to arrange the three windows.
The two outer ones should be open while the middle one remains closed.
Go past the hanging clothes and turn left again to see the three candle holders.
You know guys, I heard Kermit the Frog's voice very recently.
And I realized that what I sound like doesn't sound like...
Doesn't sound like...
Doesn't sound like Kermit the Frog.
Hello, welcome back.
Light a candle and place it in the middle.
Walk around the hall following the sound of a baby crying until a passage opens.
Then go inside and take the baby monitor.
Bring the baby monitor to the parents' room, turn it on, jot down the code coming through the monitor.
What?
I was explaining everything that we have to do in the next part.
Okay, so we gotta go to the peepo room.
Again?
Well, we will eventually, yeah.
Um...
Okay.
Okay, so go to...
I think I remember where this one is.
The mirror room?
Do you wanna trust...
Do you trust me?
M'lady, do you trust me?
I think it was the first one you broke.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Do we go to the clock room?
Yes.
Is that where we go?
Okay, I know where the clock room is.
Okay.
Oh, the comfort.
It's right here.
Do we need the hammer?
I don't think so.
This isn't the clock room.
No, you just passed it.
You had it.
You passed it.
It's the one right there, yeah.
It's the sign.
I was gonna say.
Okay.
Now you're gonna use the note to change the clocks.
You got this.
Oh my god.
What was the sign?
You can read analog clock, right?
Okay.
6...
3...
30...
12...
36...
Okay, remember that for me.
Okay.
6...
Nice.
3...
30...
The...
Okay, this is not...
Oh, wow, that's messed up.
That's so...
Wait, this is so messed up.
Okay.
3...
30...
And then...
12...
30...
And what was the other one?
Um...
The plates.
Wow, the guide says...
2...
30...
That means it's wrong.
Oh, fuck.
That's messed up.
Okay, and then there was one more thing.
Wait, no, no, no.
I think you're right.
No, it...
The paper says 3...
30.
I see it though.
Look.
I swear to God.
It says 3.
30.
Oh, my God.
Is it because it's like...
Almost to 3?
Oh, no.
I don't think so.
Oh, maybe.
Wait.
There's no way.
The guide is wrong.
No, I don't think so.
It's...
It's 2.30?
It is?
Oh, my God.
I...
It looks like 3 though.
It does.
Wait, it's locked in place.
No, the guide is wrong.
The guide is wrong.
It's locked in place.
Yeah.
That's messed up.
Stay like saving.
Okay.
So, um...
Hold on.
There's a...
So...
Now turn left.
Continue following the hall across from the...
Hanging clothes.
Okay.
So, yeah.
Keep going.
There's three windows.
Uh...
How'd you know?
The paper.
It says it on there too?
Yeah.
Oh, I didn't see.
Wait, let me see.
I wanna see.
Oh, you're right!
Yeah.
The two outer...
Yep.
And then what?
Um...
Now you're gonna...
Keep going.
Oh.
Who's humming?
Okay.
I think you just keep walking.
It says there's something about candle holders, but...
I don't see them.
Oh, okay.
There's no can...
Oh, wait.
Maybe here?
Oh.
Yeah.
Grab a baby monitor.
Oh my god.
I need two hands.
Why do you need two hands to hold the baby monitor?
I...
I'm sad.
Why does it make me use two hands?
Gibberish, gibberish, gibberish.
Alright, so now we go...
Just grab any!
It doesn't matter!
Just grab one!
There's 200 of them!
Okay.
Alright.
Now we go back to the parents' room.
Okay.
Can you save?
Where's the parents' room?
Oh...
Remember where...
Where's the attic?
Yeah, yeah.
You gotta go through the attic.
Like...
Fuck.
Ugh.
Can...
Does the parents' room door, like, just not open?
Or is it, like, weird?
What do you mean you can't use that here?
Shut the hell up.
Bing bong.
My...
My sanity is really red.
I'm a little concerned.
Is she chasing you?
No.
I don't know anymore.
I'm just going into the room.
Yeah, just go to the room.
Just going into the room.
Go to the safe room.
Okay.
Alright.
Put that on there.
Very nice.
And put that on the baby monitor thing.
This is the base of the baby monitor.
Where the fuck do I put this baby monitor?
It just says bring it to the parents' room, turn it on, and jot down the code.
Oh, there it is.
Zero.
Three.
Seven.
Five.
Zero.
Three.
Seven.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
So bring Dolores the baby.
Um, wait.
The 10th mirror is located in the second floor bathroom.
Seven.
Did we break that one?
Five.
Zero.
Three.
Seven.
Five.
Zero.
Three.
You mean there's a mirror in the fucking bathroom?
Two.
Three.
Yeah.
Five.
Well, um, there's only this one.
This is the last one you have to break.
We're so...
Toki, we...
It's this one, and then one more, and then we're done.
We're so close.
There's one more after...
We're almost there.
45 minutes.
We can do this.
I trust.
I have to go back to the basement that you don't understand!
I have to go back!
You just go to the basement and then you come back...
You got this.
Later time.
You don't even have to remember the code.
I have a cheat.
Where is it though?
Where is the mirror?
Wait.
Actually, go inside and look.
I think I...
Wait, go inside.
I see it.
I'm pretty...
Is it this?
No.
Turn around.
Why are you...
Why...
What are you doing?
What do you mean?
There's nowhere in here!
Turn around!
Go inside.
Over there!
My fucking god!
Oh!
This is why you need to look!
You need to use your eyes, doggy!
Back into the hallway!
Spin!
Wee!
I wish this was a fucking cutscene!
I...
This is so unnecessarily obtuse.
Like, it's just so...
Wow!
In our favorite place!
Alright!
Go grab the sledgehammer!
And then...
Um...
Through the poop chute.
Okay.
Nice.
Get to the sledgehammer storage room!
Okay.
And then we leave.
Yay!
Let's look at this hole!
Is it safe?
I wonder!
After the 40th time I jump through it!
Is this a safe hole?
Whoa!
Yippee!
My god!
It takes so long!
Okay.
Back to the Christ room.
Yeah.
Alright.
Okay, back at it again.
Hank!
Because this...
Because Dolores had to just...
Lock up all the rooms!
Oh!
And she turned off the lights!
And all!
Thank you, Dolores!
Thank you!
Second floor bathroom?
Oh!
No way!
Oh my god!
I fucking hate you so much!
Can you use your...
I don't...
Where am I?
Oh, I just...
Dolores just killed me.
Oh!
Oh my god!
She turned him back on!
We didn't have to do anything!
My head is so red right now.
It's okay.
It'll go away.
We're in the safe room now.
That's the last mirror I think we have to break.
Oh my god!
Now it's PT!
Now it's...
Wait, go!
Turn...
There's a...
That?
Yeah.
There's a cassette tape on the table.
Okay.
Um...
Look up at the clocks above each hallway.
Go through the hallways in the order indicated by the baby monitor code.
What?
For example, five would be the hallway which displays five o'clock.
So that one.
That's five o'clock.
Three...
Seven...
Did you go the right way?
Okay.
Five...
Zero?
So then...
Midnight?
Right?
That one?
Probably.
Yeah.
And then X is three.
Three?
There you are.
It's this one.
That one?
Yeah.
Straight?
Wait, no.
Yes.
And then seven.
Seven...
That one.
And then three.
So straight.
There you go.
It's the baby.
It's just a fucking baby.
Wow.
Who recorded this?
Oh my God.
Sucks.
Who recorded it?
Holy...
What the...
Wow.
No touchy...
Wait, where am I?
I'm back in the...
She stuck me in her womb?
Yep.
We're going back, guys.
Back where we belong.
We're gonna rock a pipe, baby.
We're gonna get on board, guys.
Let's go.
I'm free.
Oh my God.
I can still hear the car.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Turn around, turn around, turn around.
It says, take the crank from the phonograph.
Wait, is there...
Where did the phonograph go?
What do you mean?
There's a baby.
Hello, baby.
Yeah, hi, baby.
Okay, go down...
Okay, go down the stairs and there will be the phonograph again.
Okay, never mind.
Sorry.
Return to the womb.
Yippee.
Wow, it's really cozy in here.
Very cozy in the womb.
Very nice and wet.
Yeah.
Oh, squishy.
Yay.
I'm so lost now.
Oh, this is the kitchen?
Okay.
Are there meds in here?
No.
The baby...
The womb does not have beer anymore.
Aww.
Do we really need meds anymore or...?
I don't know.
I think we're beyond that, no?
I think we're beyond saving.
Oh, okay.
It says, follow the baby crying.
Hello, baby?
Baby.
Pepe?
Pepe, are you on...
It's in here?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, yeah, there it is.
Wow.
The womb of hell.
Yippee.
I have to look at it.
Whoa, it's twitching.
Oh, it's like...
The baby's kicking!
Oh!
She's gonna get birth soon!
Look at that!
The baby's kicking!
It's a boy!
Or maybe a girl, because they're cutting off all the womb of course.
Why would that make it a girl?
Every baby has an womb of course!
You know, you cut it too...
If you cut the...
Remove it fully, it's a girl!
Is that how it works?
Is that how...
Is that how it works, right?
Wait, where do I go after?
Okay, so now...
Hold on, hold on.
I'm trying to read it.
Uh...
Install the crank on the phonograph by the TV.
That one, right there.
Oh, this one.
Yep.
Oh my God...
And then like, if you leave a little bit, then it's a boy.
It's not how it works.
And...
And then we're gonna follow the umbilical cord to the progress room, and go back into the mirror.
Oh my God, seriously?
Are you fuckin' kidding me?
Are you...
Wait, so we gotta go all the way back upstairs?
Wait...
This one?
Yep.
Oh my god.
You can see how I wear it in my head.
My mind is so red right now.
Like, I'm not gonna be alive at this point.
Dolores, don't do it.
Dolores, please.
Okay, and then where do I go?
To the progress room.
Oh my god, Dolores, you fucking bitch.
Oh my god.
So, you're going to the confessional, basically.
Okay.
Don't have my baby body.
Or, yeah.
Okay, yeah, just keep following the cord.
Okay, yeah, keep following the cord.
Oh my god, that's the baby.
Oh my god, the actual baby!
Oh my god.
You fucking bitch.
This is actual baby safety.
You need to pick up the baby.
You gotta make sure your hand is, like, above the, uh, below the head.
To keep the head safe.
It's cradling, it's cranium.
Oh god, he turned gray.
I'm gonna take you to the confessional.
Yeah, take him to the confessional.
I'm gonna baptize you, baby.
No, not here, the confessional.
Oh.
This one right here.
I don't know how you would know this.
I have no idea.
What?
Oh, here, I just chuck him in here?
It says, pick up the baby from the crib, bring it back to Dolores in the confessional.
That's what it says to me.
And watch the cutscene.
I equip the, I equip the baby.
Can I drop the baby?
It's not looking so good.
Can I?
Look, he, he looks so old.
You should keep this with you for now.
I wanted to drop the baby.
I'll, uh, yeet the baby inside.
The, what, how do you do this?
I'll give it to her.
The baby goes into the square hole.
Just actually.
Yeah.
Why doesn't she take the baby?
Dolores, don't you want the baby?
Dolores, take your goddamn fucking baby!
Uh, let me look up another guide.
I tried to take your stupid fucking baby!
Uh, uh...
Oh my god.
Hold on, I have to, I have to...
I'll stay in the womb, I'll stay in the...
Um...
She can't get me in here.
I got the baby with me.
What the hell?
Oh, next cha- What?
No, I'm in Dolores' chapter.
Why isn't it...
It doesn't even talk about the baby.
Wait.
What?
What am I...
I'm just...
Hold on, I'm re- I'm trying to read!
What?
Drop the baby!
I tried to drop him!
Go back in your crib, little baby!
Go back!
I don't want you no more!
I...
What?
B- Baby?
I don't want...
I don't want to...
I don't want a baby!
I...
I don't know.
I don't know what to do.
I have no idea.
She's in the mirror room?
Where the fuck is the mirror room?
I have a baby in my hand!
Mirror room?
The one on the first floor?
Why does it say confessional, then?
In this... I have no idea.
Where's the...?
Go to the living room through?
Oh my god.
Where... Where is that?
Oh, come on.
Oh my god.
I can still hear the car.
It's taking me out.
Oh, the confessional in here?
Oh, wow.
Okay.
I think she's in there.
I think you give it to her in the hole.
The square hole.
Here's the square hole.
The baby goes in the square hole.
Square hole.
You are forgiven.
Oh no.
I don't think she is.
Where did... Oh my god.
He came from heaven.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Now... Uh... Yes.
You did it.
Uh... That was the moon mobile.
Then we can go to... Wait.
Okay.
Note that you have... Have... Wait.
Note that you must have completed all ten puzzles before you can start this one.
Head to the parents' room.
Place the mobile toys on the...
crib.
Crib.
Oh my god.
And that will give us the key to open the last... That door in the basement that we couldn't before.
Yeah.
Then we can... Oh my god.
Someone's at the door.
Rude.
That's my delivery.
That's my pizza.
My head's not okay.
My head is not okay.
It's fine.
My head.
It's full red.
It's fine.
We're about to go... We're about to go into the room.
We're about to go into the room.
It's fine.
It's full red.
We're about to go into the room.
Go in here.
See?
We're fine now.
Okay.
And now put that on.
And then... What do you mean you can't use that here?
Shut the hell up here.
Okay.
Do I spin it?
Oh.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, cool.
Oh my god, I was about to say... How did anyone... How did anyone beat this?
I don't know!
How did anyone beat this?
What is this contraption?
Oh my god, I swear to god, I was like, if it made me go somewhere else, I swear to god.
If I had to go anywhere else in this godforsaken house, I swear to fucking god.
Okay.
Now...
Alright.
Go open that.
Alright, I open this now.
Nice.
Vinyl disc.
No.
Wait.
No, it's not open.
Oh yeah, we gotta go to the, um, the basement and use the phonograph down there.
What's wrong?
I have to go to the fucking basement!
Yes!
What?
That's where the last door is anyway!
You had to go there anyway!
Man, I am not sane right now.
I'm...
Man, my...
My head is not okay anymore.
Can you turn any of the lights on?
Or did she actually flip the brake?
No, she flipped everything.
There's nothing left.
Okay.
We'll just run, I guess.
I don't know.
Oh, I don't know.
Just run again.
I don't know.
The car still is on.
You're good.
Wee!
We make our own fun, you guys.
Nice.
Alright.
Okay.
Now to the phonograph.
That's right next to the TV.
We?
I bet you I'm gonna get, like, shanked by someone here.
There's no way.
There's no way we're freed.
We're here.
Alright.
Okay.
You can use it to play music.
Or music.
Alright.
Oh, that scared me.
Now what?
Um...
Uh, listen to...
Hear the music begin playing from the mirror next to the electrical room.
So that mirror right there.
The one that I, you know.
Follow the sound and you will reach an area...
With a web of concrete stairs going in all directions.
Okay.
Follow the sound of the music.
But if you hear growling, you're going the wrong way.
That was nice.
I like this one.
Is this right?
Okay.
Oh.
You're growling?
Yeah, me too.
It's like down there.
It's like, yeah, down there.
Where's down?
Oh, there was down on...
You were heading towards it.
See right there?
You gotta cross over though.
No.
I guess you can go this way too, yeah?
Yeah, the thing is.
This way.
That was me.
Could you tell?
Yeah, your stomach, yeah.
Oh.
You're going the wrong way.
Um.
Uh.
Where'd the music go?
Um.
Where's the music?
Oh.
Um.
Uh.
Oh.
Oops.
You can fall?
Sounds like it.
Okay.
Oh my god.
How far are we?
This is... After this?
After this?
It's basically the end.
No, but how... Oh my god, okay.
It's back to the door.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Thank goodness.
Okay.
Turn around!
Uh-oh.
Just kill yourself, I guess.
Kill yourself!
It doesn't even let you... It doesn't even let you...
I thought it didn't even let you... It doesn't even let you...
It doesn't let you correct it.
It's so messed up.
It's not my fault.
It didn't correct itself.
Yeah.
Okay.
Wait, what's in that window?
Oh my god.
Got the growling already.
No, turn around!
You're going the wrong way!
It's here.
Clearly not!
We're going the wrong way!
But it played the happy music.
It's not anymore!
What happened to all the happy music?
Okay.
I'm a little lost.
Maybe I have to...
Go back to where you came from.
Why does it sound like...
Why did all the happy music go away?
Oh, there it is.
Oh.
Alright, to the left.
I think it's...
That door over there.
Do you see it?
Which one?
The one in front of you, but it's down a little.
Oh, maybe it's here.
Maybe I was wrong.
No, I think it's still a little...
How do we get there?
You just keep going around.
Like, maybe that one up there.
Maybe that one up there.
I don't know.
Right here?
You see that?
Yeah, that one up there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, we gotta...
Figure out those stairs right there.
I can't with this growling.
It's here.
We drop down and then we go up.
Yeah, do it.
Should be, right?
I think you're right, yeah.
There's...
What?
Why is it like this?
I think I should not have dropped down.
Is it bugged?
No way.
Um...
Yeah, I don't think I should have dropped down.
Why does it sound like it's pooping itself?
Where am I?
Oh my god.
Can you try opening it anyway?
I don't know.
I fuck up.
But we're gonna drop here.
Yeah, drop there.
Oh.
Okay.
What?
Try it.
What's the harm in opening it anyway?
It won't let me open it.
Oh, okay.
Then...
Maybe here?
Hold on!
Can we go down?
I don't think so.
I think we'll go further away from it, huh?
Not great.
Yeah, but it sounds so far away.
Like it's definitely tarp...
Oh.
We're done!
Wait, someone said...
As long as you can hear it, it's the right way.
Okay.
So just keep going...
Wait, we just went this way.
Yeah, but there's no other doors this way.
Unless it's this way?
You see that?
Is that staircase lead over there?
Oh, we can try it?
Yeah.
Okay.
Try this one.
No?
No.
Get her.
Oh.
Wrong way!
Okay.
Oh my god.
This is...
This is like...
This is like hot and cold right now.
I know!
Wrong way!
Are we gonna get DMC'd?
I'm pretty sure it's classical.
Some people...
Wait.
Oh, it's growling.
It's growling.
What?
This is the only way.
Go here?
You're gonna step on that.
And he's gonna growl at you.
Some people still claim classical music, you guys.
Oh, that's true.
Because it's the orchestra.
Some people, yeah.
They'll like...
Is it here?
People will just register whatever the hell they want.
And say...
The right door is not against the walls.
There was a path I missed?
But it didn't grow at me.
Yeah, we've been going the right way this whole time, apparently.
Unless...
That one?
Right there?
Nope.
It's like...
What?
It ain't grow when I'm here.
Yeah, this seems correct.
Okay, but like...
We go this way?
Or this way?
I don't know.
Yeah, so far so good.
So far so good.
Okay.
Alright.
So far so good.
Okay.
Just keep going.
Is there anything in there?
Oh!
Try it.
Hello?
Yeah!
Oh my god.
We're in- We're in the- We're in the room.
We're in.
Oh My God.
We're in the room.
We're in!
Wee!
Oh my God, they finally upgraded our- Wee!
Oh, we're back in the dirty womb.
I can see why this was the scariest level.
Because it actually is just the most nonsensical.
Yeah, there's like a lot of psychological shit going on here.
I don't feel psycholog... I feel like I've taken mental damage.
Oh my god, the cartolitis is still going.
Oh my god.
Hello?
People!
I'm so sad.
Oh, there she is.
Dolores!
Hello, Dolores.
Hello.
Hi.
She's going to stick her finger in there.
I'm not allowed to see it.
JK, I have this area.
Hello, Dolores.
I can watch from here, too.
Oh, she's got the baby.
Oh, she has the baby.
I stuck it into the square hole.
Now she's happy.
Peeping on the grandma.
Peepo, Peepo, Peepo.
See, the Peepo is the best part of the chapter.
I told you, all things lead to Peepo.
Oh.
Why'd she...
Why?
Grandma, why?
Is she okay?
Um...
How did she get up there?
Yeah, how did she... how did she get up there?
Oh, maybe the hole that we've been like...
Oh, I found it.
Oh my god, it's over.
There's a tape.
Wait, don't forget the tape.
There's a tape?
It's on the ground.
Where you got the mirror?
Oh, there's a tape.
Oh my god, it's over.
Oh, there's the rope!
There's the rope!
Yeah!
See, I told you we could do it all today.
Hey!
The breaker still is out.
I'm... I'm going out.
Dolores, you... you nasty... Ooh, you rascal.
You little rascal, Dolores.
But now you don't have to go through that stupid way to get to the basement.
You can just do it normal.
Let's just go to the confessional.
Our safe place.
Nothing bad happens to the confessional.
Look, we did it!
Yay!
You did it!
It was definitely the worst level.
So far.
That was...
That was definitely the worst level.
But we did it.
I...
We did not have the fucking ScreenRant.com.
The guide us here that.
I...
I don't know how we would have made it.
The fact that...
The ScreenRant one was so much more...
Like, so...
Actually, so much easier to follow that...
There was like a NeoSeeker.com one too.
And that one...
NeoSeeker!
That one is terrible!
Don't follow that one, you guys.
It's so bad.
The surprising part is that even with the guide, it took us almost four hours.
To figure this out!
Wait, can I show you something funny?
Yeah.
Hold on.
What is this?
What screen...
I'm sending you a screenshot.
Okay.
I just licked it!
That's pretty good.
Sorry, guys.
I can't show it.
It shows you clicked on it too!
What?
Oh!
Just because...
Just now I did.
Cause I was like, what the heck?
I was looking for walkthroughs, you guys.
Also, it shows your video too.
Nice.
The grandma chapter.
It shows Doki's stream as...
When I search Visage grandma chapter, it literally...
Doki's stream shows up in the Google search.
It's the algorithm.
I'm trying to game the algorithm.
Now people will use my playthrough as the guide to beat the grandma chapter.
Oh my gosh.
That actually...
That took so much out of me, like mentally.
I'm so mentally drained from that chapter.
Wait, is the...
Is the...
Wait.
Hold on.
Is this a speed run?
What?
For the grandma chapter?
Yeah.
How fast do they do it?
How fast do you want to hear?
How fast do you think?
One hour.
30 minutes.
Is it 30 minutes?
Is it...
19 minutes.
19 minutes, baby?
How do you do this in 19 minutes?
19 minutes and 19 seconds.
There's no way.
I...
They did not do this legit.
They must have like...
Fucking clips through shit.
Oh, okay.
Actually...
Okay, wait.
Wait.
How is this possible?
The video is 19 minutes, but their timer goes for 40.
Oh, it might be in parts.
They like split it in parts.
They probably cut it, yeah.
Just to like make it look more impressive.
I knew it.
There was...
There's no way.
There's no way in 19 minutes?
There's no way I can carry...
Even if you're a coward.
Like, even the fucking...
With the hammer.
There's no way.
There is no way.
Yeah.
Well, I think you just need to know where to break all the mirrors and then you break them at once and you don't have to keep...
Yeah, I guess like you get the muscle memory of like how to walk in the fucking dark all the time without the...
The...
And then just like...
Like, I guess they said like when you're in the mirror, the grandma can't chase you too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So she just like went in the mirror every time.
Oh my...
I'm so tired from that.
Yippee!
Dude, we made it to Niagara Falls!
We made it!
The road trip is finished!
Oh, I'm tired.
And then we... Oh, you have your meeting soon, too.
I know, I gotta go, so...
Oh, yeah.
I knew we could finish in time!
Oh my... I think if we did not have the guide, this would have been a three-party.
Like, an extra three-part on its own.
Oh, yeah, three-parter, yeah.
Now we just have one more chapter.
One more chapter, and we're fucking free.
Woohoo!
That was the most unlinear chapter out of all three of them.
Yeah, that one was... That was, like, all the backtracking.
We should have saved last week's for this week.
It was so good.
Yeah, that one had so much backtracking, and everything, and, like, puzzles, and... Oh my god.
Well, I feel like if you could just store the... the hammer in your storage... I think if I could hold the fucking hammer...
Storage?
Yeah, it would have been fine!
If I could have the hammer in my... I don't understand why I can't put a fucking hammer in my pocket.
I don't understand.
I don't get it.
I think my jean pockets is big enough for a giant hammer.
I agree.
Or you could put it, like, you know, put it in my pants, you know?
Is that a hammer, or are you just happy to see me?
Jean pockets on guy jeans are, like, so deep.
They can definitely fit everything that we had.
Yeah, exactly.
I agree.
Yeah.
Well, another chapter done, Mint.
We did it.
I would stick around longer, but I do actually have to go, so...
Yeah, GG is Mint.
GG!
We have a good meeting.
Thanks!
Bye-bye!
Bye, everybody!
Say bye to Mint, guys!
Bye-bye!
Alright, everyone.
I'm really tired.
I am...
I'm, like, already approaching disassociation right now for this chapter.
Oh, my God.
You know the crazy part is that you guys were like, oh, the husband is now in that level.
Like, he's gonna chase you.
I think we have not seen the husband, like, after he stabbed me in London.
After he stabbed me there.
We haven't seen them, like, at all.
So, I don't know how the fuck we RNG that out of the way.
I...
But, anyway, guys.
Um...
Thank you, everybody, for coming.
I hope you guys enjoyed watching chapter three of, um...
Of Visage.
We have one last chapter left.
And then we'll be free.
Oh, my gosh.
She disappeared.
Hey, guys.
I can't save her dog.
I'm gonna...
Looking...
Sleep now.
I know.
Like, it's 8 p.m.
I'm gonna go to sleep.
Because I'm so tired from that.
It took a lot of mental power to power through this chapter.
Uh...
With all the, uh...
With all the backtracking.
And the puzzles.
And trying to figure out where to go.
And the hammer time.
I hope you guys enjoyed today's stream.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.